une petite question pour vous tous
comment s'appelle la bonne femme qui
vont devoir maintenant dans les selles
zhu qui fait les photographes comment
elle s'appelle elle est assez connue en
fait
elle le connaissait au point à temps là
tu veux que je te laisse meublé à m'en
faut que je réfléchisse pour réussir
votre pièce je pardonne aucune idée mais
elle s'appelle comment en réalité
bon pari que personne ne connaît donc
elle s'appelle maria et emiliano va il
faut l'être photographe valérie député
depuis cinq ans déjà je pense
ici brienne et l'est de la ville de
novossibirsk
bon la mahatma donc les grandes heures
vont tous comme on s'y attend je suis en
train de chercher des caméras espérer
trouver celle
d'ali reza
qui normalement doit être la caméra
numéro 4
mais qui semble pas fonctionner
pour le moment bah écoute c'est pas que
roy début adressé ce jour que tout le
monde quand même rien
attends attends attends ça peut-être
buggé les caméras ont peut-être fait
bugger non ça va ok juste ya un problème
avec les caméras donc
on va on va laisser les partis commencer
je propose qu'on se met comme ça du coup
je pense parmi les grands joueurs
d'échecs rapport est le deuxième après
andy mon devoir le chevelure à la
rockstar
oui ce n'est que deuxième je pense qu'il
y avait il ya recueilli en avant
avant toi aussi bien
aujourd'hui
mignonne les photographes tout à fait
d'accord
par contre ces photos
je pense que moyen
on est calme ce qui est un peu non je
pense qu les verts plutôt la chevelure
dans un taux plutôt mapad en star du
rock
camille cailloux les chevaux mon oui
mais pas les
choses les chevaux bon pour la ligne
je joue que oui mais bon du tout a
ajouté mme bard
réciproque
j'essaye de comprendre pourquoi on a pas
pourquoi il nous manque les deux cas mme
howa bizarre
ça peut arriver je sais qu'ils ont fait
des tests ce matin
tout à fait d'accord la bonne nouvelle
ça commence en retard un black pour le
moment or au
compte
twitter
c'est dommage en plus on a besoin que de
la cam 4
j'essaye de régler le problème la ddt
mais tu aimes bien ont vu son regard
d'elecam globalement oui j'adore parce
qu en fait sur leur expression de gueule
on peut voir parfois beaucoup beaucoup
plus que
sur leur cou quoi
parce que maintenant j'ai l'impression
que ce pelouse la monte de plus à la
montre de cash et laisser les émotions
maintenant ils font tous plus ou moins à
la guerrier alors
il montre maintenant ce qu'il pense
je sais pas si c'est pour du mois le
portugal mais ils le font surtout
quelqu'un comme
niveau par exemple
il montre ce qui ce qu'il en soit ce que
et leur sens
je sais pas si les partis ont commencé
aussi ce sont des des cours à zara en
quelque sorte ce que je vois les joueurs
applaudir si si si ça ressemble à la
vérité sur tout les cas surtout les
catégories qui en fait donc rajapaske
qui a joué des quatre c'est pas la
partie qu'on voit actuellement pour le
moment
je vais on va réussir à voir la caméra
mais il va nous falloir
malheureusement les amis un tout petit
peu de temps donc on a bien la partie
de radjabov qui a joué des 4es et je
suis en train de
pour le moment on va être comme ça
et on va voir un dépôt qui a répondu
instantanément et alireza qui joue
cavalier f6
surprise ou pas surprise la tsca relief
si tu t'attendais plus à une slave n'en
a pas tant que ça se joue aux quilles o
la soif c'est levure turquie au il a
joué
souvent dressement mais peut-être que
pour cacher
donc cavalier 6,6 est tout à fait noir
parce que vous si tu te rappelles jeudi
que la deuxième option ce qu'il voit
jouer l'une des gammes piste de danse
lente et capitaux d'un donc on ne sait
pas exactement
quel est donc cet ordre de coups et est
pourquoi parce que sur calais 6 3 il
aurait dû au jeu alors les mesures sur
cale f3 il va sûrement jouer de cinq ans
comme le fait déjà combien ils viennent
de faire maintenant donc soit je trouve
à soi que valls 3 je pense qu'ils
auraient jabbour joue plus souvent que
relaie ces 3 par contre il est capable
de sortir je crois au quatrième aussi je
pense qu'il est plutôt genre de
choristes roi maintenant après quoi elle
est réservé à pajot fawcett sur presque
sûr qu'il va pas jouer ce 5 alors après
que les 3l va faire soit fou 4 soit ceux
ci soient qu'à hollywood hills est très
possible que parce que je voulais pas de
cet être très près mme
g me convient et assez gravement topal
viennent aussi
donc tu perds tu pousses marine revient
au super u know viens donc me plutôt
faut beau cadeau c'est si je suppose à
thiant de serre
j'ai pas vu encore aller les affaires ça
m'est possible que j'ai oublié quelque
chose maintenant à leurs intérêts
semblent si rajab offert 4 est-ce que
c'est fourbe 4 ou bien pensant que très
à la mode maintenant oui
oui on sait pas parce que bay 5 malgré
toutes les tentatives de réfuter cette
ligne d'apparence
doute aux pires sont réussis encore
d'ailleurs je vous félicite et moi même
je félicite que il est choisi le centre
parce que ça va
ça va mener au jour beaucoup plus
excitant que robot cadres
se traite double tranchant je tiens de
vous rappeler que grâce à cette ligne là
y'a quoi il ya deux ans nakamura boitchu
de manière très convaincante car c'est
parce que les juges neutres à lisette et
4 au premier deux garçons avec cette
ligne la
leçon intéressante en fait quatre ou
cinq
maintenant les boîtes doivent plus ou
moins joueuse sans que les 2,5 et
prendre sur buzz 5 pour espérer quelque
chose
aurait dit j'étais juste en train désolé
on est on est un peu
dépassé par le fait qu'on voudrait bien
voir ali reza donc tu dis la ligne les
lignes assez récente avec 5 assez
excitante gelé beaucoup analysé j'ai
failli trouver l'avantagent convaincant
pour les bourses de faillite juste
pourtant j'ai vraiment essayé quoi donc
avalé de saint calais 2,5
après quoi comme les p 6 hélas comme tu
dis emplettes au ras du cou il y avait
eu beaucoup de parties dans cette ligne
là ça leur dit donne toujours mieux aux
blancs est en réalité c'est très très
chaud moi pas leurs titres et fois lors
du très fort il comprend que c'est c'est
compliqué à appliquer parce que l'ordi
d'un niveau correct jean profondeur
32-33 ils donnent un net avantage la
wii maintenant donc faut aux deux
possibles oui fou étroit possible oui à
4 est possible même pour pouvoir reculer
sur à 3 précise avec les dés de taper
sur ces quatre direct comme ça oui sinon
qu'on sait
l'époque moderne un peu toujours
considéré sur n'importe quel courage 4
parce que c'est l'époque moderne c'est
l'époque d'après elle choisir aurait
donc
je pense que radjabu à une ses positions
plus qu'une seule fois puisque ça a été
jouée dans une partie radjabov si rogers
grand jester paris 2021 donc ils ont
dirait pas de ses positions tous ces
gens là jouent aussi souvent qu pas
évident de se rappeler de tout ce qu'ils
font disque bas qui a exactement le même
position avec les noirs actuellement au
top 16
dénoncer une seconde position en fait
hein c'est pas avec le noir j'imagine
c'est que veut dire quoi ce que veut
dire peut-être qu'ils aubois qui a
participé donne les prépas de
relance pas j'aurais pas le top 16
donc là il doit il doit être en train
d'essayer de se rappeler de ces analyses
radjabov
doit bloquer on réussit toujours pas à
voir ali reza c'est un peu frustrant à
vlad
c'est un petit peu frustrant mais qu'est
ce que j'aimerais le voir comme aux
attentes mais on essaye de faire avancer
le truc on a on a des gens sur place 1
qui sont qui sont sur la technique comme
c'est surtout nous qui sommes intéressés
par cette caméra là c'est pour ça qu'on
ce qu'on se bouge un petit peu on peut
jeter un oeil rapide à ce qui se passe
entre les deux joueurs qu'on voit à
l'écran howell réalité
alors donc maintenant on parle de dingle
pommier chi
cette ligne est très à la mode depuis
pas mal d'années déjà
oui et
j'en ai un bon spécialiste d'ailleurs
sur cette ligne peut-être le plus grand
spécialiste de cette ligne en fait c'est
guéri mais je pense django
aussi maintenant je sais pas soit donc
je pense que fufu e7 ici c'est le coup
de blues à la mode cavale et a6 aussi
faussé 5 est ici n'ont sûrement à cause
de b4 se pose donc soit faux soit qu
elle s il faut si vous voulez quand même
assez prudent pour ne pas donner des
tempos développement à boire un jus info
social
donc moi je pense que j'ai beaucoup
analysé fawcett jeu plus pour qui
je pense que j'ai de gros son analyse
ici mais je me rappelle pas de tout
faire surtout ses 5 tu vas avoir des
idées comme cavalier prend 1,4 des
quatre
à voir mais ça pourrait mieux possible à
13-6
au caire on va essayer de naviguer un
petit peu entre les parties donc alireza
pour le moment seriez vous et 3 c'est
intéressant ça avance et oui les des
deux ou trois ce que ceux qui ont
souvent le banc font aussi par exemple
qui viennent j'ai pas un truc comme kobe
ce 6 non il faut possède par exemple je
n'ai pas à 3 par exemple par exemple tu
chauffes eau au collet 6,6 par exemple
je joue dans ceux de jouer par exemple
fawcett par exemple je joue autour de 1
et une fois et tu t'es rock je veux h4
c'est solidaire et je veux corriger 5 ou
10 pires loupé la tour donc tout reçoit
tours je crois c'est ce que j'ai donc
fait peut-être la tentative la plus
fiable de réfuter ces directs âgées et
mis les coureurs comme silent way
juste l'aider
il a fait 46 direct au et donc comme je
dis si tu veux poursuivre ce pensent à 3
mais peut-être c'est pas très malin de
poursuivre ce point parce que c'est
sûrement le point le mieux analyser par
quelqu'un qui choisit cette ligne avait
tout noir
voilà
et à quatre noms sont encore possibles
ou pas oui mais je pense que tu as plus
donnent vie à faire ça avant faut trois
passes qui ont maintenant une fois l'eau
cavaler sur ce si sûr à 4 il ya collé à
5 et à [ __ ] quatre échecs surtout donc
tu veux plutôt jeux à 4 avant fou 3 pour
pouvoir parer ça avec photo d'eux en
fait en vérité sur académique cavalli
sait si c'est aussi une idée tu veux
jaillir sur la case b4y à 5 oui mais bon
joueur dans l'esprit oui dans l'esprit
c'est un futur garderai donc ça fait pas
sens de faire à 4 après carré lisse et 6
owen juste pas un an d'août avoue logis
au top au plus tôt à 3 pour
sécuriser la table sur ce deux breaks
contre hull 1 15 b 4 pour faire affaire
d'âme ses 2es pas se faire chasser parti
rallié b4 ouais c'est assez logique
as tu en as
il ya des gens qui ont la caméra 4 je
vais faire je vais faire une tentative
les amis
le seul danger c'est que ça peut
ça peut faire couper le stream pendant
quelques secondes
mais bon et on peut pas se permettre de
pas
ne pas avoir cette caméra
donc je vais je vais faire
je vais faire la tentative
souhaité nouveau chance
à tous ce qui par
est ce que ça marche
est ce que ça marche ou pas
non ça marche ça marche pas mieux
wayne on s'est passé s'est passé ça fait
ça frise mais c'est passé mais
mais on n'arrive pas
[Musique]
on n'arrive pas à la mode
c'est quand même très frustrant
tant d hec
n'arrive pas on n'arrive pas à s'en
sortir running gag avec les camaro mmc
qui font les tests
ils font les tests le matin en fait
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué vu
qu'ils organisent pas les choses au
moins 48 heures à l'avancé qui le font
deux heures avant
obligatoirement
oui donc attendre la partie de
2021 au lieu de fou ou 3 et là je à un
chip leader ici avec lebron et au lieu
de vos droits et les jeux call est roi
ce que je trouve bizarre in use
in your leurs intérêts
donc ouais faut 3 qui laissait système
mais c'est pas une bonne nouvelle à
callière rezaï jouent tous tempo et que
rajab office met déjà aussi tôt dans la
partie à réfléchir au final
surtout dans une position aussi complexe
parce que ça veut dire qu'ali raisin
peut réellement jouer le gain
aujourd'hui je pense et une position qui
lui convient comme un gant
contre radjabov je dis oui il est vrai
mais tant que les poèmes viol que
sécurisé et n'être pas agressif ici donc
ne pas choisir les points valaient alors
à toi ton pseudo oui c'est assez
facile pour un jouet à cultiver de
brenda et donc le couffo eu 2 2 radjabov
montre bien ce que je dis avant de
partir une fois en face d'un truc l'eau
dans le don ils s'entendaient pas il va
commencer de brand qu'est ce que vous
voulez
l'homme se sont-ils ou et
de blindés non je veux y allume son
style le style de rajab ours blancs des
bondons alors il prend trois points
derrière bonfoh cette même ça ça a été
prévu alors ok a avec un voisin a
prévenu le nul dans cette partie est-ce
que sur rock j'ai s'inquiète un coût
plus ou moins dans ce style là il a
gagné l'autre partie oui
med à l'auteur pratiquants mais mouradia
bien déconner avec son cavalier trois
noms force est donc ici je suppose tant
que t'as pas fait cette connerie là
quand même jeu 5 et autres quand même
bien trop tôt quoi
bien trop tôt sur un qui va faire déjà
je suppose tu veux faire je sens qu'une
fois qu'on m'en fous sur pc n'est ce pas
donc
bon je pense que sur petits roquets va
faire plutôt petit rock ambiant qui est
fou bessette et une position mais ça
peut être une position qui tourne quand
même d'un côté ou de l'autre
non toi tu t'attends à drum
bass j'espère de me tromper mais je
mange et gimmi bruni attendrait à on
nous dit que fabiano en train de
surprendre
hikaru ce message en suis pas un bon bah
c'est pas une surprise du tout mes amis
quand même on l'a pas en caméra non plus
dire
ok d'ailleurs j'ai deux mots à dire sur
cette pause l'un d'eux que juan monaco
morin qui viennent
bon c'est qu'une berlinoise d'accord un
tipi le noise pardon
je pense pas que le choix est très bon
parfois bien nommé bon et fo des six à
part du fonds trian autres courges et en
ce que voulait de cette nuit après quoi
les branches locales et 3 par exemple
par exemple au but 6-5 maintenant par
exemple que les fuites oui parce que
dieu était d'accord de
permettre échanges se fout moi les
conditions que ton cavaliers arrive sur
les meilleures positions
ici c'est eux s'ils souhaitent envoyer
pointures est un peu passif par compteur
pour les noirs jouable pour 10,6 c'est
les premières l'interdît depuis
longtemps et d'habitudes comment ça
s'est passé donc les banques jouent soit
2,4 quand les de cette
école est de 7,2 que le sens que le 5-fu
5,4 ou de quatre roues chambre f5 et
maintenant soit dans me2 direct soit à
mort cinq jeux 6 d'un modèle
d'ailleurs les deux sont complètement
différents d'accord bon beaucoup
d'analystes parient que se tiendrait au
caire haut lieu de
4,3 aussi pour mettre le coller sur ses
cadres et sur fond ces quatre bouffer
avec berry le terrible col et 3 je sais
que ça existe mais je pense que le coup
est assez récent événement il ya un lien
à 1,5 pour aller toucher le pion
bessette
oui alors à cette position-là après
comme les a5 est apparue en pratique que
pouvoir
option 2000 guest
est
donc
dans les deux cas les noirs ont réagi
grandes rock je pense que grande roue
que naturel parce que turbo est beaucoup
moins naturel ou et
je suppose des lieux quoi soit fou de
2,4
soit à trois points 4 je suppose je sais
pas qu'est ce qui est mieux il faut de
toute autre manière il faut bouger là
quelque part est donc un peu 4 je pars à
4 ou ses quatre enfants il faut il faut
faire quelque chose dans cette direction
d'ailleurs possible que le coc blessure
à cinq voix était bien telle règle qui
tourne autour du roi sur ce week end au
fait qu'il ya la camorra par ce matin
c'est plutôt bon signe pas pour fabien
non parce que
parce que on va dire il est vrai que
dans des positions compliquées en a
comme rat est tout à fait dans son
élément mouais fabiano est un très très
bon en attaque heureux et en plus
fabiano s'est très bien se préparer oui
ces analyses peuvent aller encore trop
loin peut-être joué encore même six ou
sept coups parfois et ses ancêtres il
paraît de tels postes comme matt oui oui
parfois parfois mais ça peut ça peut
être très très dangereux je pense que
grand roque y doit y réfléchir à deux
fois parce que ça se peut que l'analyse
de fabiano est il vraiment très très
loin mais en connaissant fabiano un peu
sûr que tour bruit et les analyser aussi
livré mais bon ça tu dis que tout
rebelle 8 au mentorat une partie grande
tu peux juste perdre sans jouer un seul
coup ouais
oui malheureusement est si tu joues
grandes rock il est possible qu'ils ont
il faut qu' un pas que le nombre
d'adversaires
c'est parfois bien nommé
stockfisch
17 qui vient de sortir ahmadi
il ya quelques jours mais quelques jours
en finlande au musée les volets du
hockey et on peut retourner on apprécier
ce bressac écouter me panis puissiez ce
niveau c'est parce que vous connaissez 6
si j'ai bien compris votre question duda
duda groupe i do i do qui grimpe pas
encore vu mais on n'est qu'au début
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
on retient de cette fois-ci dauda et un
mot de rapportent ils jouent un ratage
heures fourcade je viens ça déjà
n'empêche le cou aux abymes
a l'air d'être giga préparait ce qui se
met à réfléchir assez tôt l'été les mecs
d'offrir 4
est pas près fines les des seniors
premièrement e5 père après connaissent
et six boeufs o 5 d'envoi sans infos sur
trois c'est facile et ouais
et les autres trucs ceux qui ont si en
visant les cases des six en provoque des
6 et hambourg sur ce site le truc c'est
que récemment à l'ordinateur adore de
déstructurer avec les besoins partout
partout de les siciliens
l'ordinateur il est plus cool des firmes
et les colons c'est semer ouverte pour
la tourner en noir sur 6 8 il est plus
cool donc
et il est cool même dom et des eaux
noires de construire ce centre mais
comme quoi tu es un peu le tour parce
que quand les noirs vont mettre la tour
sur bourges aux puces 3 et concret a pas
de problème
enfin dell et les théories bien sûr les
choses comme souvent sont beaucoup plus
compliquées photo 3 câbles et 1,7
bon
du coup
retournez sur
firoud djadja il ya bien eu rock rock
cavaliers ses trois tours b 8
donc sable en deçà blanc sec
kirin si tu peux retourner sur la pause
pour une minute sur la pause rapporte
j'arrive une seconde
ici avant faute de trouver s'il te plaît
oui ici avant bon c'est juste ici
cette partie gagnée par les bons jeux
mais surtout par les bois ok donc c'est
pas si c'est pas si rapportait ce que
comme prépa de duda
2020 ils seront des trois c'est une
nouveauté qui n'a pas surpris à leur
rapport que le sait pour houda il a
l'air très tranquille
ah ouais mais peut-être se joue sa
nature
alors je comprends pas
il est quoi et les plus gros que moi
je veux le bide
chez les voisins que sont bi des plus
grands lieux que l'on vient
c'est pas évident pourtant les gars
c'est le big man tu penses qu'ils lui
font xxl
apport oui quoi à temps mais lequel est
joué 23 24
c'est leur ombre 5 non non c'est pas
l'ombre c'est le pitch vaujour m-watch
des lipides comprendre le truc je
compare avec n'est pas à la personne
ah ouais ouais mais paul est en train
d'aller aux toilettes pour voir est-ce
que son bide est moins grand que ça à
jouer ça a joué par contre ça il ya
beaucoup de courbes on retourne sur
anyresa un petit peu
qu'on n'arrive toujours pas à voir la
cam malheureusement mais on va retourner
sur un lit raisin la 5e' qu'encore la
théorie on va laisser les deux hommes en
sortir
alireza il rock rock de peter boyle
tempo et
non une autre fois il a fait cavalier
300 autres forces est
en travaux
attendez je vais essayer on dit qu'il ya
peut être une solution
ça va ça va reprises une bâtisse le
monde
la crise est tous des alcooliques
c'est la critique des actions de
l'équipe du bidon ça va ça va couper
puis ça va revenir la ddt
attendait ça va ça va le truc contente
on va on va avoir deux petits frise
on va avoir un freeze vlad ça y est ça
marchait au la personne technique nous a
nous a aidés
et ben voilà on va pouvoir voir enfin
ali reza la caméra
sauvé par
par la technique
sur sa langue âge corporelles et les
séries il a l'air très serein ah ouais
y'a un william saurin d'ailleurs
peut-être qui
sait le temps d'expliquer le coutour de
huit puisque j'ai dit j'ai développé un
tueur une petite souris pourquoi tour du
web je pense tour bride passe comme ça
ils neutralisent
il veut neutraliser le colis à quatre
nous
parce que su recoller à 4 ya que relais
à quatre
ça c'est un problème pas où est
possiblement donc oui il met la tour sur
hbo 8 prophylaxie parce que comme ça
après damas quatre ils voient beaucoup
et direct sur b2 parce que sur m6 lie à
tours 2
voilà
attend laisse moi me poser deux minutes
vlad regarde on savait qu'on dit qu'il
ya des très beaux tableaux en derrière
on en profite de ce musée
sur sur les images
comme tu vois alireza il a l'air très
serein regarde les bras un peu comme ça
comme on a besoin on croit tapas et à
bras en croix au et owen ne sont -
s'appelle comme ça où croiser les
il a l'air de comptes en pays la rd
encore connaître non en fait il a rien
juste de content oui oui bien sûr très
tranquille
tel un bond doctor psycho il a bien lieu
dans son adversaire qu'il adore roamware
son cavalier sur ces 300 jamais z a
forcé quoi oui oui donc il a gagné un
tempo
bras croisés ouverte à corriger
croisés et radjabov qui al'air dessus un
peu quand même non sassus attend peu non
bon bon bon malheureusement pour lui
c'est pas vraiment une ligne où se coule
deux ans proviseur parce que tu as eu
raison ce qu'ils ont ici dans cette
ligne sitôt
mais c'était pas précise il est vrai
c'est très facile de devenir moins bien
avec les banques ça peut aller très très
vite un masque et le faux sur presbytère
excellent parce que la case des 5 parce
que le cavalier bleu sera menée sur 2 5
par pékin par exemple il ya pas mal de
sujets ou les bois pour devenir moins
bien
donc c'est bien sûr d'ailleurs c'est
maintenant je sais ça traîne de traits
dire ce qu'il pense mais
il est en train de penser à ces choses
là c'est vrai qu'en fait si tu échanges
le cavalier pays 6 contre ces trois
équipes et la d'amendé 5 c est le flou
bessette ça a l'air d'être très vite
mieux pour les noirs ça peut ça peut
très aller très très vite en fait
et donc il veut y réfléchit à quelques
où tu penses quel coût et professionnels
à trois quand même
pas ok à 3 ou we too soon hwi
ban quelque sorte qu'ils viennent même
temps un professionnel
je suppose avec les des cycles évocateur
tour d'arles
je passe professionnel pourquoi parce
que la dame sur scène regarde quand même
le pion sur ces 4
mais bon ce que ça peut pas quand même
allé très vite c'est quoi ton prochain
coup en fait aux cavaliers de 2 un truc
comme ça toi
parce que une fois tu as mis ton
cavaliers sur b4 tu peux plus bouger sur
2 3 wii est sûr qu'on est étroit et a
toujours des trucs à la damb ans
et tu commandes recommence de poser les
questions et sur fois j'essaie toujours
de trouver ça je me rappelle ça je me
rappelle c'est un thème récurrent c'est
ça reste hyper content oui oui bien sûr
rien comprendre et même avec lourties
masculin en fait je le redis donne à 0
mais s'élève j'ai analysé cette connerie
là pendant deux 2 jours annie rêver à
quelques conclusions c'est tellement
compliqué que je me rappelle même pas
quoi exactement
sauf que je vous ai dit le point avec
dans le dos à 3 a tourné en h4 est très
intéressant
donc
là d'une question que le 4k turbo 2
dames c'est 6-2 dans ces quatre bateaux
de deux jours sur le coup mais suffisant
donc j'ai répondu à votre question ses
formes par les femmes parties quoi
est ce qu'il ya un dress code pour
participer au tournoi je me suis pas
renseigné mais j'imagine que s'est tenue
correcte exigée mais comme souvent tu
sais pas trop ce qui rentre
dans la tenue correcte pas il a joué à
troyes tu vois d'ailleurs il ya une
question qui va tout faire qui viennent
vous le sentez le musée
c'est ce dont je parle c'est ce que
kevin moi dit il y a deux heures donc
personnes descendent le musée ici et ça
fait juste aucun sens ah ouais ouais
les réalisations de cet été est parmi
les plus compatibles wi faire ça dans le
musée où tu
serais bien bio être juste mon appart
quoi ça fait absolument et les chaises
comme chen bing et tout le reste et
c'est peut-être ton appart d'ailleurs
on y prête à temps verser les caméras on
voit mal les chinois font n'est pas non
plus là pour voir l'échiquier quoi on
est là pour voir les joueurs ça 300
écouter à trois c'est la prophylaxie à
trois c'est le préfet lac simon en gros
à trois week-ends c'est pour préparer
dame ce 2 à 3 certes un gros qu'à une
seule chose élevé au moins ternes en
gros il veut jouer dans cette chaise
dirai ça news
et donc aller au resto se préparer pour
demain enfin et en europe europe et est
ce que il l'a préparée
mais comment il veut gagner pour tirer
ça nul demain mais
comment ne veux gagner le tournoi rétive
effacer les iran que les autres essayent
de le battre oui en employant les
stratégies de douze judokas
en utilisant l'énergie de ses
adversaires
les plus hot tub donc tu me feras
pouvoir
l'opus le plus grave tu vois ton baiser
je viens d'expliquer aux formes et les
plus tôt
19 ans demain a dit reza
je pense qu'ils s'en fichent son
anniversaire constructive on aimerait
quoique assommage elle les anniversaires
se fait encore
faire passer un certain âge celle
inverse
ouais bon là y'a plein d'options pour
les noirs c'est le premier coup il
semble vraiment réfléchir non qu'est-ce
que tu
n'as il a l'air de réfléchir mais paraît
pas non plus d'être méga concentré il a
l'air plus de contente d'ailleurs il a
rien de quoi réfléchir ici parce qu'il
ya une fois l opium est mis sur a3 tu me
la joues toujours ton coller sur à 5
pasquio
ok j'ai la pure de me répéter toujours
mais comme tu vois un trou tu rentres où
elle va taper sur un an et des 4000 à la
extrêmement tranquille ans et je parle
de chute
merci exclusivement
donc là qu'ils avaient les betteraves à
arriver au prochain coup
pas forcément prochain mais en fait
c'est une menace nous obligés d'exécuter
en vous quand on veut ce que lecavalier
à 5 il est pas si mal en réalité parce
qu'il défend ses quatre oui oui bien sûr
mais il libère le bio c'est bon pour un
joueur arrivé sur ce 5 et d'un scénario
là si les noirs arrivent doom
affaiblir 5 et pour devenir vraiment
mieux quoi parce que ces cinq attaques
de 4 ça peut être renforcée par la tacc
du fou sur bruxelles sur trois ça peut
être renforcée par la tacc du cheval sur
b3 donc ça peut être vraiment une idée
pour
devenir mieux
donc radja est parti aux toilettes mais
malheureusement - manteau à liszt dont
il va pas trouver les réponses il
coulait pour lui
quoique le pain bah ouais mais c'est
bien vu de la part d' ali reza de mettre
la pression et autour de suite oui tout
de suite rires là il ya une chose
importante à rappeler c'est qu'ici a pas
de rajout de 30 secondes
avant le 60e coup donc le temps que qui
lui reste
1h35 là c'est pas afficher valoir que je
vais je vais je vais l'affiché c'est
vrai que c'était pas prévu dans ce
design de la face en dessous s'associent
les toilettes de chroniques
les toilettes portables
mais ça peut être pratique
très
qu'est ce que je veux c'est donc à temps
je vais essayer de rajouter
les pendules assure
sur ceux sur cet écran ça va me prendre
un tout petit peu de temps
pour qu'on ait les temps
comme il faut
parce que c'est vrai que c'est ça va ça
peut vite devenir important leur
les temps de réflexion et les temps
restant vlad à l'époque d'ailleurs blum
et mageot s'oppose à l'époque radja
a été un gros titres aborigènes qui en
fait
maintenant plus le cas parce qu'il est
bien solidifier son répertoire et les
perdu ses illusions au niveau de ce
qu'il peut obtenir aux échecs donc il
est devenu beaucoup plus aux pratiques
dans son jour par exemple les blues
jouent plus vraiment à l'estonien de la
partie classique donc mais sinon pendant
très très longtemps que ça a été un
très beau john key grave quoi il était
toujours en date ouais ouais
surtout avec le noir d'heure
et ça lui a coûté cher
aux pas tant que ça en fait basculer tx1
danser et notre juste exxon l'un des
meilleurs de tout le temps peur
comment un choisi radjabov en tant que
wild card qui viennent a expliqué c'est
parce que pendant les candidats présents
dans le pur liquide impressionnant il
devrait jouer mais il est refusé à cause
de la pandémie donc cette fois ci ils
ont compensé donc
les derniers candidats en invitant
expliqué un homme a expliqué un way
simplement et sûrement noctua lui reste
plus qu'une heure 33 déjà à timour alors
qu'il reste encore une heure 52 alireza
c'est quand même une grosse différence 1
et on est à peine au douzième coup donc
c'est quelque chose qui peut jouer au
cours de la partie
qui est la différence je ne vois pas une
1h30 de pur un timour oui 1h52 pour ali
reza
ouais c'est pas malin et un plus haut ça
je suis sûr qu'on furent usa depuis
quelques années auparavant mais depuis
quelques années c'est un pur produit ce
métier en tant que joueur d'échecs oui
je peux quand même prouvé ce que je dis
je suis sûr que pour ce type de position
et les entamait des dizaines de partis
de tri mois en blitz en rapide et un
classique même en classique et même en
voici quelques unes mais surtout une
rapide parce que c'est l'alphabet dos
les méthodes de beauté unique donc si
vous voulez ici il n'ya pas que les
réflexes
d'un
manteau moyer les mêmes le marcquois
il ya la pratique il est toujours sûr
avec she pitié pas avec gragnic avec
sûrement d'autres ils se foutent bien la
manche est-ce que ça arrive que certains
un jouet
les parties d'entraînement avec
l'ordinateur c'était sympa l'ordinateur
seul mais george peppard enough et un
ordi où ils essayent de choisir des
coûts non
mais qui s'intéresse à ce que leur dit
va te dire pendant deux parties quoi
c'est que pour les analyses sinon ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'est ce que
cette position peut faire donner comme
décidé à toi en tant qu'humain
j'ajoute mc2 est donc maintenant on
pourrait imaginer que lecavalier parte
parte vers des 5 avec le cavalier qui
défendent pions c4 ou peut-être je pense
qu'il ya peut-être plusieurs façons de
traiter ça une chose découvert tu
commences par faut bosser parce que moi
même si tu regrettes de firmes et à tous
sur but 8 à n'importe quel moment donné
tu peux faire x 8 ou faut prendre froid
tomber deux sites a besoin de gagner un
pion tactiquement oui donc on les avait
rien de regretter alors tu peux le faire
et puis réfléchir parce que déjà si le
type mais sa tour
assure des uns ou la tour air sur bien à
chaque fois ces deux univers différent
oui
parce que dans un cas par exemple si tu
mets f leto a emporté les 2,5 tempo au
hula
t'es pas bien ou là mais il connaît
encore j'aurais pas aussi vite si
connaissez pas non oui oui et r mais
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs il sait
vient de reprendre en fait pendant les
candidats à au mexique où g mika était
2e ex-aequo avec guy hands
pendant tout le tournoi lorsqu'il a
attrapé son adversaire dès l'ouverture
à chaque fois il employait cette
technique l'air de sortir tout du coup
tout de suite c'est
pour mettre la pression c'est pas bête
du tout parce que regardent
à radjabov qui vient de se lever il a
besoin de se détendre c'est la première
ronde il a peut-être envie de rentrer
dans le tournoi tranquillement et rezaï
ne laissent pas rentrer sains dans
aujourd'hui qu'ils voient pas pc mac a
enfin peut-être tu va pisser mais sur
ton temps
je vois c'est que tu vas dire sur ton
pantalon qua non sur ton temps car lille
est allé chercher quelque chose à boire
de fond c'est peut-être un coq à la
faute la faute
très chic parce qu'il va retourner pis
c'est à cause de ça bah oui nos gars
perdent cet os mobile est quoi et à
chaque fois l'auto voit certes il va
sortir son coup tout de suite on nous
dit qu'il ya une faute de richard
rapporte on va aller le voir sur la
grande caméras déjà pour voir si on
ressent quelque chose ça peut vouloir à
obo non là ça va être ban qui c'est qui
a dit gardera portes j'ai si ça peut pas
être une gaffe mais j'ai six ici excusez
moi mais c'est quand même assez moche
oui appeler ça une gaffe mais c'est
moche pas passible quoi est ce que ça
vaut un ban ou pas pour toi moi je pense
qu'au volet justice mais pas ceux ci se
mouiller ou bien la manque de la
compression positionnelle quoi
généralement 10 dans l'âme sicilienne
qu'on joue jamais avec cissé g6 nous on
l'a dit souvent dans les stades pour
oui c'est que je vois pour l'instant qui
ont pour l'instant je crois que le
cheval sur sept est mort
désolé de le désolé de le dire
à nos rapporte non non non un peu fin du
set non tu devrais passer quand même pas
moscou ou moins
alimentez quoi pour apprendre des choses
loin d'être fait encore parce qu'il veut
jouer avec des cinq essayé oui moi même
après des cinq le cheval sur recettes
toujours à ce mouvement
est d'ailleurs un jeu prévu les
victoires de duda ajouté
en fait la diff peut se faire sur un
caruana camurat entre nous ou thiam a
atteint mais ça va être plus tard les
parties les plus excitantes parce que
les dés sont jetés les
dés sont jetés
tout beau et comme on a prévu qu'il y
purge cinq
thèmes pau
- le coût très responsable donc sûrement
analysez vous je crois que les deux sets
parce que si les noirs arrivent à
pousser h 5 h quatre parties contre la
camorra
but est vraiment moi si le noir
réussissent y réfléchir
caruana hockey normalement nous les
les pauvrement le premier coup qui ont
un casillas est de 4,1 pour une raison
ou une autre c'est pas top
aux
antilles rock et les questions damas est
fausse et 5,6 jamais ok tour à vous tous
ici d'air
oui bah je suppose frustrant car
je vais dire en bouche pour british
airways 5 oui
oui donc dans deux faubourgs cathy
russie donc dans bush qui ôte de 3 donc
alors fou dossier c'est que les 60 est
pas top donc au moins on a compris
pourquoi pas de terrain quoi qu'ils
auront lieu doctorat d un peu des drains
peut être juste pacifique pour fois sur
des sites
de république ce rodez 6 avec la dame
aussi
donc pas d'éclater râleurs ouais les
questions alors est ce qu on l attend
pour ce 3
à 5 2 4
sagem plus
essaris hyper compliqué hein
quoi la b3 d'un mot 5 et un coup
oui peut-être ça peut-être qu elle est
éclatée ainsi tu peux te permettre enfin
ok ça peut être intéressant à on reste
on retourne sur les raisins bah ouais
il vient mettre son cavalier en d5 donc
c'est toujours la même position et il
s'est levé c'est la première fois qu'on
voit debout
alireza
et eti moore qui continuent à piocher
dans son temps puis je veux dire
quand tu creuses à creuse dans son temps
tu vas easy prendre son temps quoi
1h26
et cavaliers en d5 sa force une
réaction parce que tu dois décider si tu
laisses le fou ou trois ans prises ou
pas j'imagine que cavaler prend des cinq
on n'a pas du tout envie de le faire à
cause 2 prend ou d'un enfant qui vient
s'installer sur la case des saints qui
ont enchaîné par fougue et s'est tu à
noter qu'ici comme le fou est encore ans
et 8 même qpr en est envisageable nous
le fou pourrait après sortir vers g4 et
jouets pour ses 5 les deux options sont
un son faisable
dit moi
quand tu es un joueur
de lestienne rire comme radja pour fois
été toute sa vie tu as vraiment du mal
de la chute on fout des cases noires
avec les bois
crois moi c'est un réflexe en fait t'as
vraiment être du mal de les relâcher
donc je prévois qu'il va passer au noir
de bouffer sur trois
parce que pour moi ça a été pénible
toute ma vie quoi
wen en ces pénibles
et en fait j'ai repiqué quand même
les parties doit les réserves et il a
bien caché quand même ça préparant ce
tournoi parce que il est vrai il a eu
cette variante
compter radjabov il ya deux ans et
jamais sinon donc c'était quand même
difficilement prévisible parce que j'ai
plein d'autres trucs en fait ce qui
explique que rajaona n'étaient pas
préparés contre cela je pense qu'il a
préparé cette ouverture pour les
candidats ou que pour cette partie
je pense plutôt
bien sûr je sais pas mais plutôt pour
cette partie parce que je pense que
peut-être c'est pas une très bonne idée
de sortir ça contre quelqu'un comme que
roanne a trop dangereux un français
ouais parce que là prêt peut être bien
égal reggiani avec les blancs soit
pardon et il peut juste gagner en force
avec les blancs avec trêve niveau au
moins obtenir un bon avantage donc en
général si tu veux je pense pas qu'ils
ont ici c'est une très bonne idée de ce
tournoi de préparer moynier à kalma un
seul truc vaut mieux de préparer jeunes
aux ouvertures si c'est possible bien
content rp 4 et donc au fur et mesure
choisir content sourit ça contre l'autre
donc c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
comme pour
[Musique]
le match de championnat du monde ah
ouais non quand même cet adversaire
différentes
donc s'y passe est mais plusieurs
stratégies différentes parce que ma
champion du monde tu choisis tube tu
veux vraiment blindé un gros répertoire
et là tu veux avoir des petits dribbles
un peu partout ouais donc c'est vraiment
la proche est complètement différente et
skoda trouve que c'est pas illogique
dans ces cas-là de qualifier celui qui
joue pour le match du championnat du
monde dans ce format parce que ça lui
demandait d'être beaucoup plus complet
que celui qui joue que les mages est-ce
qu'on sorte ya pas un manque de
cohérence
peut-être mais pour moi c'est pas ça le
plus intéressant est le plus important
pour moi le plus important c'est pas
cohérent groupe accueilleront le plus
important pour nous qu'il ya trop de
monde parce que 14 ans c'est trop pour
tout le monde
pour les seconds ans jusqu'en faire je
peux vous le confirmer parce que je les
ferai pas une fois donc mais cohérent
non pas à vrai dire je ne sais pas c'est
pas les questions principales pour moi
il ya trop de partis c'est un moment
donné ça devient juste j'ai par ailleurs
genkois
ils sont et qui on est combien
bas il faut
neuf max
9 max m'a pas 14 points forts plus avec
tous ces quatre jours de repos
[Musique]
à un moment donné que ce plus haut
qu'est ce que tu vas faire pendant ces
jours de repos je pense qu'il ya trop de
jours de repos bah oui jusqu'à à tous et
ça te prend j'ai pas un mot en deux mois
après pour tes récupérer
et laisser content tu sais ton client
par jouer c'est que là que tu peux
dormir correctement pour une fois elle
revient ça y est il faut que tout
recommence
je me rappelle que
je me rappelle qu'à un moment donné il y
avait un tournoi comme ça et encore
joueur a eu ou trois secondes henry et
donc il les a torturés avec l'épreuve
quotidien et à un moment donné les
parties de jeu ça patine et les trois
seco dans son parti au cinéma et auquel
on de regarder le film donc la durée du
film normalement c'est une heure et
demie ils sont sortis du cygne mois
chacun ouah j'en ai 25 message de la
part du client mayweather vous êtes ou
[ __ ] vous pouviez déjà regardé trois
lignes pendant ce temps là tu vois et le
mec mais le problème c'est que le mec
est
il a terminé sa partie très vite et
donc les anglais pour étaient absents au
cinéma pendant qu'il a joué sa partition
à autant de sa voix là encore ça
s'arrête jamais parce que le plus dur
est guère le plus cette question à vrai
dire
et comment ils font pour apprendre
autant de variantes les joueurs bah ils
répètent quoi répète pendant deux heures
enfants et comment ils font pour répéter
il répète sur l'ordi répète sur les
criques et ils font ils font quoi
moyenne techniques par exemple ta copine
ou ta femme par exemple
toi t'es sur sa faim et
la copine éventuellement il s'appelle
sophie donc elle est ivre avait alors
dans cette variante les six au lieu de
cavale et ce trois elle joue alors tour
c'est en tu fais quoi et comme ça il
torture pendant deux heures et voilà tu
peux être sûr que ça va si allah veut
gueule tu vois répondre à toutes ces
questions là
c'est une des une des manières et ce qui
en a qui regarde juste bêtement les
fichiers sur l'ordinateur et qu'il et
repasse
et s'il ya des personnes qui repasse
simplement les analyses sur l'ordinateur
ou s'est pas jouée mollets des délais
techniques que j'ai dit mieux mais sa
demande d'avoir une copine à ça peut
être un second danse jusque feu ce poste
clef que pire ça va mieux
c'est de l'expérience personnelle
en tant que seconde en évidemment
le problème c'est qu'ils habitent le
second john williams à un as roma trop
vite
avec les copines
ça peut aller pendant longtemps parce
qu'il est vrai ça peut servir que en
tant qu'
on a tous compris on a toujours su
l'étape copier vont être compliqués
[Rires]
j'ai cinquante deux variantes de flash
voix de l'europe sophie
qu'il a joués fois 6 1 pendant que pour
rigoler alireza assez vite mais il peut
vraiment connaître aussi loin
moi je ne sais pas mais je peux check
est totale et au monde peut-être elles
suivent aux urnes deux parties et des
gros joueurs d'ailleurs
mais pourquoi radjabov réfléchir et
aussi longtemps s'il suit une partie
d'accord
d'accord donc je veux dire que masquer
alireza sais tu peux pas jouer aussi
vite
katie moore il est concentré
il a pas il a pas l'air de suez encore
vu si là il a l'air d'être
impliqués on va dire dans ses coups
mais ça donne l'impression qui connaît
quand même alireza parce que
la vitesse de ces cours
est trop important en dessous qui jouent
des bons coups à chaque fois les
couleurs que l'ordinateur confirme
alors est il le fait assez facilement
après ab est apparu que deux fois et à
chaque fois sur l'internet
et une fois au lieu 2 fois 6 les noix
enjeux
de cette
l'autre fois
je vais
donc me fois ci c'est une nouveauté mais
extraordinaire quand même que pour cette
position là ce n'est pas du tout
considérés comme l'opposition principale
à les résa quand même
les connaissent coup par coup quoi
inventer les l'impression quoi peut-être
qu'il a joués injuste dans une partie
d'entraînement aussi parfois ça arrive
que tu es un peu de bol
ouais bah ouais ça aide énormément aussi
parfois c'est de s'entraîner avec
l'ex-entraîneur de ton adversaire
tu sais parfois ça renforce grave moi
ton intuition intuition
qui sait qui c'est en tout cas il est
très bien préparée alireza aujourd'hui
et écoute s'il pouvait gagner avec les
normes dans cette première partie ça
nous mettrait très bien en ce début de
tournoi
ah oui donc ouais mais optimiste très
optimiste très optimiste du côté
français tu t'intéresses jeter un coup
d'oeil sur les autres peut-être
qu'on va se mettant en grande caméra
sur ding contre les pots
ou l'a
déjà autres ayant cours au niveau menace
moi tu en as un an
donc qu'est ce que ça nous tombe soit
les bout en bout ressurgit 4 ce qui en
fait les deux coups qu'il est beau on
doit faire soit comme les 4 4 les deux
sont un petit peu désagréable effet le
h4 et moi je corrige quatre manches mais
il faut choisir c'est toujours les mois
un moment désagréable de la dernière
mission non mais tu renforce le four
donc
si je suis humain je dis francis ou
alors parce que r3 quand même
c'est pas ça affaiblit de trucs comme un
fauve 3
wii et là je suppose que peut-être avec
lufu sur grimpeuse rbi des trios
respirer une compensation à long terme
peut-être nécessaire que vous l'êtes de
cinq peut-être connaissent à cette
heure-ci g65
peut-être juste aura de 8 après ouais le
fou sur quatre il est un peu zarbi quand
même n'est ce pas est ce que dangereux
aussi ses dents girondins criaient de
tlf blessure jeune homme
contre un tacticien comme le port est
parfois ce que veut dire que peut-être
tu peux vous pourrez un truc pas une
fois mais peut-être pendant vos encours
que tu fasse gaffe des trucs tactique
sur la cage de 2 donc mais n'empêche que
pacy briquet vous ici c'est peut-être
qualificatifs aux jeux 4 et un bouge
pour peut-être éventuellement pour fouet
avec le cavalier oui
c'est plus sécure juillet mais monte
encore de la wii mais même si tu donnes
ce pion d'insécurité quand même parce
que les pièces au maximum week est
l'opium des deux va être isolés mais des
pieds son actif le faux bond aux actifs
le fougeux dosso valdant sur peu trop à
nick et la face à l'air d'être une bonne
prépa donné ponant quand même possible
d'ailleurs semble
pas ce que ça donne l'impression qu'il a
à jouer
assez rapidement ils ont joué à la même
vitesse mais j'imagine qu'ils
connaissent encore
ouais
parce que la position à l'air
intéressante et en plus ça a l'air de
données du jeu au noir
je te laisse se laisse regarder ladd
qui a le claude juste à côté
et qui analysa font
donc 1h30 chacun je vais faire un tout
petit tour sur les autres échiquiers bat
pour m'assurer on va y revenir de ce qui
s'est passé chez 1
caruana n'y a pas eu de coups donc il
semble que la caméra soit sorti avec
brio des dangers caroit nesc et duda qui
envoyait ses cinq immédiatement pour
venir souligner l'affaiblissement des
cases noires avec l'idée sur des princes
et 5 devenir maître influe sur cinq et
d'évoquer les noirs
donc la partie intéressante à partir ou
déjà là dans laquelle il s'est vraiment
passé quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas vu
c'est celle de geely rennes contre yann
nepomniachi
l'acquis en train de regarder
ce que tu as tu as trouvé encore de la
théorie chez eux
dans la partie de ding
college au qatar est une nouveauté parce
que nîmes dont
après live
l'année dernière
annonce cette année la masse
de
et d'ailleurs ni moins à gagner le
tournoi est qualificatif si tu n'ouvres
des quilles 100% très bien préparés donc
comme je suis pour tim k fond d'argent
chez moi je suis inquiet et très
mécontent quoi quoi que je vois pas trop
tout un jeu après que les quatre jusqu'à
23 mois peut-être patte d'un jet de
gagner mon plus haut ce qui serait une
très bonne opération pour n'est pas de
rentrer dans le tournoi avec les noirs
et fair nul contre un des favoris néo
peau qui à 16 contre hd bookmakers de
l'autre côté de la manche et ça me
paraît vraiment être une côte assez
énorme comme comme le diane ventures
dans le tchat
il a plus d'une chance sur cèze de
gagner je pense à yann
c'est beaucoup ou pas là une chance sur
16 il lui donne
weedon 6% et demi de chances de gagner
c'est beaucoup ou pas c'est très peu
quoi bah moi je suis d'accord je pense
qu'il n'est pas très peu de chances de
gagner bah oui
dur qui pensent pour lui bas parce qu'un
mec qui sait que les filles et pour la
couronne deux fois d'affilée qui
viennent
vichy célestins
gironde il a perdu la couronne et il a
regagné il s'est pas qualifié deux fois
d'affilée badauds fois de fait les
mécanos qui s'est qualifié deux fois des
filets qualifié jeudi karpov
ça a été d'abord c'est parce qu'ils pour
ce match contre 400 il pille 7 et
kourtney
[Musique]
contrat pour deux fois d'affilée il sait
que les filles mais seconde personne
d'autre je pense que c'est parce qu'ils
connaissent pas
perdu comme kasparov
oui mais elle s'est qualifiée bizarre
moi quoi quand tu joues en direct le
match final oui il n'a pas fait le
tournoi de candidats il a joué le match
le match final des candidats directs en
gros il était très favorisés quoi
j'étais favorisés oui donc
situation par la probabilité c'est pas
très probable quoi que tu lui fais deux
fois défilé parce que
c'est eric maxime qu'il ya trop de temps
avec en inapte que l'échantillon soit
représentatif
hockey et voyelles ne parle comme
souvent en tant que mathématicien
mathématicien et je ferme ma gueule j'ai
rien à
répondre parce que quand même boîtier
moyen par des marshals d'à-propos pelles
et révoqué j'ai confirmé j'ai que la
firme est quoi une semaine sur cèze a
une chance sur cèze ça paraît quand même
beaucoup 1 sur 8 9 pourquoi pas mais sur
celle
bas mais j'ai dit pourquoi
si tu veux c'est soit le tournoi il ya
quand même du dépôt dans leur haine
parce qu'il ya on va dire qu'ils y
accèdent peut-être parce que tout le
monde
et pour qu'il ne faut pas quoi tu vois
peut-être mais j'ai en fait n'a
quasiment pas ta quasiment jeunes
je vous confirme un discret surtout les
russes
qui leur a fait
non commandes mais il a fait un truc non
mais c'est tout ce qu'ils ont à dire et
il est comme il est quoi
dans tous les cas je représente une très
grande majorité
je peux vous le confirme et j'en lis les
joueurs russes sont pas traîner presque
même pas du tout
peut-être un soft qui en ferait une
partie de son équipe même pas même parmi
ceux qui ont fait une partie de son
équipe et il y en a ceux qui utilisent
qui veulent pas quoi
ouais à tel point interpol
il
a requis dix mois est ce que tu penses
que mick jagger et très populaires
d'après les gens de son groupe
pour l'instance
j'imagine que oui
dans tous les cas je pense pas que
mccartney a été aimé par les trois
autres mecs de lure pourquoi
je le pense pas
du coup on aura déjà pas fille commence
vraiment à se mettre mal autant parce
qu'il va avoir consommé déjà ça va y
réfléchir encore non mais tu sais qu'il
a en fait il va se retrouver dans un
gros trail note semble sans rajoutant un
crémant oui tout ça se resserre donc
nécessaire c'est le pire moment quand
ils calquent sur un truc dont tu t'en
veux pas elle est le truc devient
compliqué d'y réfléchir la chute n'est
pas surtout pas ses hôtes a pas d'impact
tu veux tu choisis un cours ou hazard et
tu te dépêches voir vers café chute en
ce moment car après tout tu t'approches
de la porte de la c3 déjà elle que le
mot que je
moi pourquoi est ce que je suis mais
quoi bon pourquoi est-ce que je suis
n'est pour vous faire torturer comme ça
au pourquoi pourquoi je suis venu
peut-être sedan huawei parce que lui l'a
acceptée une wild card il aurait pu la
refuser il n'était pas en sécurité il va
faire après cette partie tu vois tu
penses que c'est possible qu'ils aient
un joueur qui se retire des candidats
pendant le tournoi bah oui je pense que
je pense que c'est précis où le moi
jamais parce que le même armée parce que
c'est déjà arrivé ça dans l'histoire des
candidats
non mais par exemple pour le match des
candidats ou pierre contexte mos def
non non non non non il y avait un match
ordinaire contre courtney
haut en étant menés que 2 1 je pense
donc mais rajoutent à abandonner le
match quoi bah je
mets d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je vous
confie qu est ce que je comprends c'est
agréable quand même il faut plus cool de
commenter qui vous intéressent à plasma
n'est ce pas mon cher collègue pinte
avait prédit un fou des deux tu avais
dit que les joueurs des stands y en
avait beaucoup de mal à se séparer de
leur [ __ ] cage noire comme cette mazet
et effectivement il veut jouer sur cases
noires il garde le faut tu penses que ça
ça a été dit affirme déjà aussi le fou
des deux est aussi le joueur de
leicester il comprend très bien le
d'éléments intérieurs en
moyenne que quand c'est bien fait ou mal
de dos l'eau permettre
donc là il peut menacer peut-être pas
encore mais il faut faire attention
cavaliers prend des cinq frères ou et
voilà merci me soit on se tait
l'histoire de la relève joos témoins
d'abord je voulu dire yomtov obligés d'y
devenir coach non et je me suis corrigé
messieurs donc je me suis pas trompé
messieurs d'ailleurs ça a été un bon
choix mais j'ai pas parlé de birth
mastrov les roulettes les meneurs à
vendre et deux matchs contre petrossian
écorche neu est trop sérieux il a joué
un match contre plus trop cher nos
clercs en 71
petrossian abandonné contre corneilhan
74 dans des circonstances mal définies
et à l'abandonner le toit des candidats
ans 60,2 non non non attendez mais et
mario banner n'a pas eu à moi je
compteur petrochina excusez moi j'ai pas
eu 171
où
là il écrit ça entre prestations 71
oui la villa suis fait calais b 3 en
fait il est encore dans la préparation
bof elle reviendrait d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs regardez d'ailleurs il il est
illico il suit son fou quoi oui bien sûr
ça va s'arranger cette partie comique
d'ailleurs ils devaient tous ces mecs
homme il est vrai pas une case où tu
peux le cacher sur eux en madone ces cas
là je veux bouffonne l'auto faut qu'on
laisse 4 voici lâche le tournoi à
bordeaux lâche le tournoi mais la prépa
de dans les raisins elle est quand même
restaurant
oui oui très bien comment s'appelle très
bien
choisies trouver
périr payet compteur ce joueur précis
mais c'est exactement ce que tu avais
dit dans le lot ce tram l'adus hier
qu'ils allaient chercher une idée ou une
stratégiquement mais là c'est pas une
idée fine stratégiquement en réalité
c'est plus qu'il a ciblé un adversaire
avec une ouverture vous savez parce que
quand vous jouez l'east india
vos
sacrifier autant de l'espace vous
permettez autant de choses à votre
adversaire clos pour développer votre
fonction je sais tu qu'il est vrai cette
pièce n'est donc le four de gaze noire
devient comme quoi une partie intégrale
de votre corps et donc l'abandonner sais
c'est pas que pénible c'est traumatisant
qu'est ce que c'est que ma paroisse par
ferroudja et son équipe et surtout ça ne
m'est tellement bien dans ce début de
tour un des nerfs petrossian aux
candidats de câpres avant que de 60 au
guichetier
mais urinaire 71 ça paraît tellement tôt
je n'entends pas trop quand tu parles
dans cette direction s'est qualifié il
est vrai en 1970 dans le haut valais
on nous propose fou ou trois dans le
tchat info 3 c'est un peu bizarre parce
qu'il vient de jouer fou des deux en
fait il vient de 3 donc ça paraît très
bizarre de replacer l'oeuf ou sur cette
case après je vois que c'est le coût
proposé par l'ordinateur mais
franchement ça paraît pas être un coup
jouable en réalité ça fait pas de sens
par rapport au développement de la
partie et c'est peut-être déjà
mais l'énorme peut-être déjà égalisé 1-1
ici
ouais je me suis trompé moi culpa mea
culpa il
moi je compte plus trop cher il livrait
il abandonné en étant donné qu au 01
j'ai complètement oublié ses magies
l'abandonner aussi maya cool pas
moi je n'ai peut-être parce que je
commençais de jouer aux échecs deux ans
plus tard
donc c'est moi j'la ne m'a pas touché au
nom
tous deux ans plus tard c'est moi je la
mets moi je m'auto show propose cavalier
e 4 peut-être mais bon ça laisse kamal
et prend des deux quand même d'enfants
des deux peut-être qu'on peut revenir
même en b 6
oui même si je sais un petit peu précis
quoi est ce qu'il n'ya pas des options
put non ça va sinon au niveau de comédie
au niveau de l'évolution est ce qu'il
n'ya pas d'autre option d'un petit peu
plus dynamique au lieu de caraïbes et
six au lieu de vous relier de calais 2 2
non il faut bouffer ils menacent de
prendre oui oui comment les deux tours
de dollars
ok
juste essayons comme ça qui a comme les
quatre fausses et quatre doubles 2 d'un
bandeau fosse 4
sur tourné à calais 2 3 on est d'accord
donc tu mets la tour
pas sur ça mais sur l'autre
[Musique]
kz2
d'accord maintenant
damman 8 oui l'été d'un possède un peu
cette double cette photo 5 pouces à 7
heures de route
les des primaires faut 2,5 sur cette
photo
comme ça un gain du match si je me
trompe donc à 8 est ce que tu peux y
croire ça comme une qualité de moins de
je
crois que pour un début de candidats
c'est un peu tout match quand même
hoarau qui t'ont corrélés bossis alors
toi qui est auto payet tu peux toujours
faire ça
et mais tu peux même fin tu veux dans le
dessin qu'au prochain et là je pense que
et ceux d'afrique ou
non sa plus je viens tu as joué qui
avait lieu car les voies les plus ou
moins égale
aux quais bas il est le banc menace quoi
irlande
et blanc tu viens d'ailleurs
depuis que le nail se faire mais quand
il était jeune radjabov ce n'est pas un
joueur plus offensif
nom n'était pas joueur plus offensif ce
jusque il est vrai un tel répertoire des
ouvertures qui auront quoi il était
forcé des terrains plus agressive parce
que tu peux pas jouer les indiens comme
tu joues aux capitaux et
donc il aussi l'impression d'être
agressive mais l'a jamais été en fait
si tu veux ça a été un faux seins faux
seins faux agressif au camouflage ou
info agressif ou
fait ce que je pense que fit routes
chaque année encore normalement oui si
connais juste jusqu'à 15 lits b3 il
connaît qu'un lieu 4 aussi
non je pense que peut-être quelqu'un de
juste que ca donne rien mais un moyen
d'autres il s'est dit peut-être rockets
les questions théoriques et réels ou et
peut-être depuis un bon moment ou
peut-être depuis au nom de quoi je sais
pas moi précède souvent attelage
donc je sais juste que c'est pas un
problème - jours donc
ok je vais me débrouiller sur les
chevilles à couy sur des deux prix sont
des dieux on va essayer de voir si on
ont réussi à démasquer une émotion entre
karaca baffe après la prise sur d2 il a
décidé que c'en était assez et qu'il
allait repartir faire un petit tour les
1000 pas voir même les 10000 et alireza
qui est concentrée c'est quand les boues
six tablent sur le point de 12 mois
restent à six parce que peut-être vol
l'auteur va pouvoir et va partir
et voit se promener sur son propos
retard ou non mais l'asile à l'air pour
la première fois d'être un peu plus
concentré regarde
il s'est mis la tête entre les mains
et eric donne l'impression de commencer
à réellement réfléchir ici mais joue
cavalier f4 non il connaît il a analysé
le sacrifice de qualité vlad au petit
jeu des gones est un coup dynamique tu
as deviné de fair use à guillaume piau
alors
ça veut dire qui mais ça veut dire qu'en
fait là il en train de se prendre une
prépa dans la gueule as hallucinante
timour l'équipe connaît il peut
connaître jusqu'au 25e tu penses ici dit
et la fois ce gros c'est même sûr et
peut-être ça s'arrête pas au 25e 1 se
peut qu'en fait timour y prennent juste
prépa jusqu'au bout
c'est pas ça le pire mais le pire c'est
que
elle est obligée de retourner matin et
il va pas pour avoir sa position
tranquille ouais
donc alireza il est pas
il joue il joue le tout pour le tout en
fait aujourd'hui aleri zev korman a les
réserves des vignes aux forains qu'au
fond ils n'ont pas regardé hier
avant-hier à 20 tirs et il a toi la zone
plus grand secret sur la route au titre
voilà ce que je te propose c'est qu'on
fasse pour ceux qui viennent d'arriver
on va dire qu'on est plus ou moins
sortie de l'ouverture on a une heure et
quart de jeu et ce qu'on ferait pas à
vlad un petit récap en une minute 60
secondes de l'ouverture est ce que tu te
sens prêt à faire ça pour quoi un petit
récup récapitulatif des voyages et
loisirs jusqu'à manoir en 40 secondes
alors ce goût des cats a pas de 5 la
soif parce qu'il a trop souvent joué
dernièrement donc olivier ce qu'a réussi
ce qu'il faut un peu moins souvent mais
quand même c'était possible de prévoir
aussi que les trois de cinq cavalli si
trois décès il l'a presque jamais fait
qu'une seule fois et après au 4 x 4 est
en cours normal et se voir et jouer
millions foix et boussens c'est une
ligne un petit peu rare mais qui devenu
très populaire et six mois au cours de
derniers 3,14 on est donc de 5
obligatoire si vous voulez les avantages
que vous les deux sens que le beau 5e
volet v6 pour trait principal même s'il
ya encore floues eux deux et à quatre
comme les coûts principaux fois trois
faucons les c6 maintenant le google i o
truc le plus intéressant pour les voir
en tant que l'idée d'obtenir l'avantagé
à 3 dance 2 dans tour des années h4 plus
tard mais non radja et solide parce
qu'ils sont dépassés aujourd'hui donc je
veux de haller fawcett d'impôt petit
rock du rock maintenant que les trois
pas forcément souvent juin tourbeux huit
jeux le plus souvent dans cette
position-là à 3 pour sécuriser la place
de la dame sur ceux d'un corner 5
l'impôt parce que en juin à 3 les noirs
les blancs on a oublié les cases trois
ans trop souvent les noirs ils vont dans
les deux cas des 50 m pour parce qu'il
connaissait les positions votre manteau
fo à doha parce que comme il est
passionnant c'est un tempo alors faut à
six nouveautés sinon faut que cette fois
ci sont joués deux fois 3e maintenant il
vaut sûrement à bouffer sur e3 déjà fou
de deux cavaliers eux trois ils
continuent de chasser lufu des cases
noires parce que c'est pénible pour un
joueur de l'estudiantes de grossesse
vous comme le 4e volet de deux
maintenant que les v6 est solide moi un
petit peu oppressif comme les f4
sûrement a analysé par contre risque ici
c'est pour analyser mais comment
analyser pas risqué alors maintenant ce
qui nous attend c'est très intéressant
parce que pour ces quatre tours bordeaux
dans deux fosses 4 turbo ou des haies
dames à 8 et savoir comment ces coillot
merci vlad pour ce petit récap deux
minutes pour ceux qui viennent d'arriver
et retardataires qui du coup ont pu
revoir la partie en avance rapide ça va
couvrir le souffle parce que je me
souviens d'un 7e mais 1er
mars
hitwise
normal
donc vlad pronostics après après 1h15 de
jeu victoire ali reza il a pris les
devants dans cette partie déjà ton avis
où ça reste équilibré ici je l'espère
mais je pense que ça va être quand même
news presque radja est un très bon
défenseur et
calculateur et la position quand même
rester archi solide donc je crois pas
vraiment quand même aller victoire
lé reza ici même si qu'est-ce que je le
veux bien qu'ils viendraient france et 4
à sare et on prend b2 d'un prend b2 fou
conséquente c'est sûr il réfléchira
après à au développement de sa tour f1
en b1
mais peut-être silvio pointe et il voit
juste c'est la taule oui c'est possible
c'est possible parce que peut-être assez
le plus solide
oui peut-être un jeu pas elle va faire
un truc un truc à l'âge mais alors juste
lâché la tour du saas et pleutre non
cavaliers detroit qui viennent quand
quelqu'un te soir ces analyses à cette
réplique speed quoi je peux dire que
tout le monde peut être
un truc comme ça comme égal mais bon
oui mais tu sèmes quand tu veux mettre
ton droit sur eux deux en fait elle est
assez solide et si l'auteur va chercher
h2o qui va toujours chercher c est oui
donc en fait c'est assez solide malgré
tout parce que loge cheval sur ktm quand
même un truc bien un très bon planteurs
quoi je sais pas si on peut dire blanc
tourne peut dire un blender l'important
c'est qu'on comprenne en fait si on
comprend ça se dit
donc france et 4 jouets et la radjabov
s'il va réfléchir on va on va jeter un
oeil à son visage
barré dallaire assez calme encore un
pour le monde est mort
mais par contre regarde sa main gauche
qui viennent pendant nos stream je pense
que tu parle souvent de l'aimant gauche
de joueur d'échecs oui n'est ce pas et
là maintenant pendant quelques minutes
il les bouge sans cesse son soutien et
le
mythe de l'histoire sur demande
et avec le même geste je pense que le g7
est très parlant
comme quoi
non non messieurs il se sent pas un
confort et alireza qu'ici encore levé 1
il connaît bien sa position le joueur
français qui nous gratifie d'une
préparation xxl ça promet un pour les
autres partis est ce que tu t'es
augmente un petit peu les chances là de
victoire ben ali reza dans ce tournoi
après après 7h30 de hameaux conditions
ce puits entre auto messieurs c'est bien
trop noir croteau mais bien sûr bien sûr
la façon de cooman d'un jeune souveraine
devait s'ouvrir et anthony roux va rien
il avait quelque chose cette année la
sortie tout
paraît quoi c'était impressionnant comme
un c'est impressionnant s'est renversée
karwan
sck juanes
quand même nom mais encore mieux encore
nommé parce que je souligne ça n'était
pas très souriant c'est el escorial de
l'escorial de la souriante en fait c'est
ça a été tout en bourse ne voit rien
louis et l'ama sartigan même
sa mémoire tu vois et faux bond je sais
qu est ce que c est impressionnant à
côté moi
c'est assez impressionnant
qu'attend
jeter un oeil voire pas bientôt
d'ailleurs bientôt mais a mis une heure
à inhaler karkwa mais il lui reste plus
que 550 ti mourant il est dit n'est pas
bien le joueur azéris on verra bien qui
rira le dernier
c'était une tentative
un peu raté mes tantes et quand même
en tout cas on trouve quelqu'un de nos
écrits qui au-delà est en train de
dominer la
donc peut-être jetons un coup d'oeil sur
les routes ouest
plus
11,56 maintenant cinq ans maintenant
et c'est que profondeur 23 genre de truc
généralement contre oui je vais le
répéter la boîte de quelqu'un c'est pas
ma blague ils disent avec un gros ordi
c'est déjà plus de et demi est ce que
les noirs sont ok ici dans cette
position et la boîte par mois demandez
aux cavaliers sur 7
tu sais sur quoi c'était les blagues
dogou fils de est-ce que les variantes
si mich sur le stand est bon a demandé
aucun religieux des voix a demandé aux
collégiens donc là marion de ses miches
je vais essayer d'expliquer mais il nous
faudrait une ouverture qui permet de
faire référencer niche c'est ça ouais
oui et maintenant avec les défauts ou
trois tomes de doute ces terrains est ce
que les variantes est bon demandez aux
cavaliers je vois là
ça nous a permis du coup ça nous a fait
sauter un peu automatiquement à la
partie d'iggy rennes mais j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas jeter un coup d'oeil
on a compris que duda était bien à cause
de ce camion recettes côté ding comment
il s'est débrouillé pour échanger ce
cavalier 1 sur l'a15 et là je h4 il
attendait que l'auteur de triomphe et
que l'autre fait en cours à ses deux
heures qui viennent
parce que quand tu peux ici
l'amant veut jouer que voler ou 3 de f5
la main pour porter l'eau pions sur
quatre et quand tu prends de l'opion sur
le cac travers ses structures de pions
je parle des pions doublé de louis xi ku
band aussi le foot je dois en tant que
mauvais tient plus des trois pour casser
donc c'est très positionnelle alors f5
c'est très très positionnelle mais par
contre défendu sa part avec un puma avec
une pièce c'est pas du tout celui de
positionnelle quoi
même c'est peut-être nettoie se traîne
mais presque mais dans un autre sens
quoi les mecs capables d'être brillant
mais il est aussi capable d'être mate
les premières parties de l'est fera
sauter est capable d'être brillant arar
mais il est aussi capable d'être mat oui
voilà bien
ce qu'ils ont bien sûr me rend très
heureux quoi aller dink
aller au premier type
hollandais chinois quoi donc lord il
propose la petite turbine qui propose de
faire b5 avec l'idée sur pions avec les
dettes au bord des quatre avis et
d'aller aussi r d sur six mois et offrir
un cadeau aux cavaliers à 6 ce
qui certain moment donné tu vas sortir
sur ce 5 mai le plus important se passe
pas sur ces 5 le plus important c'est
pas sûr des six est d'ailleurs la dame
sur cinq peut être très mauvaise c'est
ce que j'allais dire le fou en ce sens
qu'il est doublement mal placé pas ce
qui bloque en plus la dame sur sur ce
coin de l'échiquier allez allez allez
mounting la chine champions
est ce que c'est moi
mais nous on peut faire aller
[Rires]
si je pense que rza c'est son nom je
sais que c'est un truc bizarre avec les
noms ira n'y paraît avec les indiens je
sais à mende son nombre de familles
séparées au nombre de boîtes de famille
se dit jonathan et c'est presque
toujours ça chez les incas ce qu'on
apprend enfin que leur nombre de
familles en fait c'est pas leur nom de
famille est ce que son frère c'est
mohamed reza lui c'est ali reza
j'imagine que rza ça doit être son
patronyme oui oui bien sûr les rues soit
c'est vladislav comment et voilà vite
évanoui je pense que rza cesson
ivanovic oui à toi et les résas juste
reza quoi
aller à leurs réserves face à alice est
le fils de raisin mais c'est quoi le à
l'équipe de foot de chartres
là je vois là josé d'un mode créative
en font quoi mais peut-être sacré
[Rires]
bon fabiano ils tanguent fabiano pas si
bien préparé que ça ah non il a joué
quelques coups pardon on a eu 1 c'est
pas un bug il a joué des quatre et six
dames dès 3h 5d prend 1,5
ou là à l'heure maintenant une chose est
claire encore une fois il va prendre
s'il va prendre sur cinq avec un pylône
il va jouer h4 c'est clair parce que
comme ça et le foot bly le contrôle de
jeu 5 et est donc oui sur corner 1 5
alors ils voient sûrement bouffer avis
cloud fou pour ne plus haut point ses
acolytes 5 et feu qu'est ce qu'on va
faire après jusqu'à intérêts donc là
donc maintenant fou aux 5 est très
triste parce que c'est sûr qu'un jour tu
vas perdre se tient presque donc
reprendre avec f et puis comme aller
s'éclater et une chose à
houdan c3 d'abord ou d'astronomes je
sais pas je sais pas bonne chose écrire
que d'apparence un anneau il ya des
trucs comme le 4 et le 5 fu il faut
calculer excusez moi je ne suis pas
capable de toute façon on ne veut pas
passer trop de temps sur cette partie
non plus on sait pas c'est compliqué way
compliqué mais j'aime bien les bons ce
que peut-être vieux rien dire danse a
été prise prise oh là là mais le roman
le roman écoute mon positionnement c'est
fou toujours ce foutu eu les bons mots
justes tout normalement tu peux pas
obtenir ça
dans une virtuose contre qui que ce soit
c'est normalement être jaugé pas dans un
opus one
2200 oui mais tu vois jamais obtenir sa
juste c'est qu'il est un très mauvais
signe pour rapport parce que peut-être
il est juste pas de niveau
cap [ __ ] où il n'a pas le niveau oui et
cavalier e sur cette voie confirmer ce
que je dis
c'est peut-être un loose cannon aussi
alors rapporte
oui metellus cannes en tant que tu es à
50% - anne oui mais quand tu as moins
trois de plus andrew scan sénégal nous
[Rires]
ç'a toujours pas joué côte alireza l'on
va retourner ça fait un moment qu'on l'a
quitté ça fait une petite dizaine de
minutes et ça réfléchit encore côté timo
si moore qui se met qui se met dans la
merde on va dire des choses comme elles
sont 45 minutes s'il garde la qualité ci
peut avoir droit à un design est assez
compliqué surtout qu ali reza c'est un
des meilleurs joueurs en rapide du monde
un des meilleurs boxeurs aussi un ouais
je commence à m'inquiéter pour les
supporters l'azéri la sq y en a beaucoup
dans le tchat
c'est vrai que tu t'inquiètes vraiment
pour eux
au fond de ton arme qui est inquiète
vraiment pas inquiet je suis inquiet je
me dis ils doivent pas bien
donc c'est pour ça j'ai menti a dû
supporter je me rappelle à l'époque il
ya 15 ans quelque chose comme ça quant à
passer à côté de l'échiquier de dragey
tabiou j'ai pas presque d'entre aux
trois parties sur quatre qui ont été
menées au temps comme ça les a
normalement ça voulait
juste rien dire et donc cette fois-ci là
je peux vous assurer un truc
chercher davantage
cherché qu'il le coup le plus précis
pour tenir les avantages matériels et
c'est pas du tout son cas maintenant il
sait pas tomber le pense mais maintenant
ils cherchent qu'est-ce que loupé le sûr
pour en faire un petit nul pour tous
des passages 12 vous l'assuré je
sais ça sa préoccupation
la plus importante
donc par contre pour cela il était
souvent très très bon
qu'il aurait pu être le scénario dans
cette partie là si c'est des personnes
avec le noir imaginons maintenant c'est
pas affirme personnes avec moi
radja trouve une manière de donner la
tour pour simplifier les pauses égaliser
à 15,5 trouve une manière on lutte pour
processeur pourrait changer d contre c
est donc comme ça pour affaiblir eu cinq
personnes retrouvées moyen de rentrer
dans une finale avec le pion aux cinq
fébrile et puis à 6-5 roi je sais 3g 6
et jouer comme ça pendant 40-45 où a
priori il aurait gagné contre ces
adversaires là ce qu'il a fait millions
fois dans sa vie c'est le scénario
classique des bars h et hippiques
d'aller partie de moi que nous voilà
on nous demande si réellement il reste
21 coups à jouer pour radjabov en 45
minutes honnêtement c'est pas énorme non
c'est pas énorme sur paris ajoutant il
n'y a pas les 30 secondes par coin je
rappelle surtout quand c'est les prieurs
partie et c'est pas sûr que tu es si
chaud que ça parce que il est vrai t'as
fait partie d'un trio - le problème
c'est qu'il s'échauffait de les parties
d'entraînement souvent ça ça veut dire
que c'est pas tout à fait comme jouer
les parties rien fait ben c'est
différent ouais père d hyper cool de
chauffage chauffer sur ta cuisine oui
mais pas d'un homme musée quoi
enfin est-ce que tu te rends compte que
c'est encore un musée j'aimerais bien
avoir une caméra pour voir si vous
cachez plafond aussi
écouter me montrer nos seins bonne
velasquez quoi qu'est ce que vous faites
là ce qui nous émeut des musées ma
couille à voix chaleureuse points comme
johnson assume ans après ce point comme
c'est quand même en fait c'est ça le
vrai d'art c'est juste que le logo de
tchatche.com oui en fait j'ai compris
c'est pour cent à d'accord c'est juste
pour voir le lyon vert quoi
mais attends je vais voir je jette un
oeil sur le parce que les américains ils
ont un oui de jeu par commente
hellénique d'autres sur le fond et qui
au fond auraient pu mieux résisté
révolte oui c'est vrai que à un moment
donné
il était en ces moments là et les teda
la liste des dalits il a eu plusieurs
propositions
donc d'analyser lé et il se verrait que
la proposition américaine a été
ami en plus grands paquets quoi sur les
propositions de 0,7 cette histoire est
connue à ces hormones les rumeurs
après il aussi peut-être que le fait
qu'ils soient américains naissance à eux
aussi peut-être joué dans sa décision
sans aucun doute
comme dans plusieurs cas d'air
pourquoi elle s'est cassée de l'état les
phobies vous connaissez cette expression
américaine quand vous connaissez pas les
réponses où sont les problèmes
chercher les questions de financement
là c'est qu'ils viennent jouer un
vient mettre la tour j'ai l'impression
c1 a donc ok ils tombent pas gâteau est
fou il donne alors
qu'il va jouer qui a validé trois tiens
qui viennent qu'il y ait dix ans clint
je viens de voir un truc il ya dans ces
trois que je ou complètement oublié que
vous laissez un dom ces quatre jeux
complètement oublié d'en haut et d'en
2,5 alors et ça bien sûr une voix
populaires alors que d'autres plus tôt
dans des 5 d'ailleurs
d'après tom 104 52 plutôt
oui
va pas perdre complètement oublié
l'existence de dames c'est trop
dans tous les cas je dois dire que avoir
tiré aujourd'hui il est vrai que je vois
pas grand chose il a l'air d'avoir
trouvé le coup le plus sûr
à notre ami a dit moore et 20 turquie
dit à propos de rapports qui est
vraiment ils jouent pas eu vraiment une
mauvaise partie
mais il est vrai bayor qualité 3 c'est
pas un seul coup qui est peut-être en
continu
la chasse aux trésors
de 5
qui s'est
révélé g3 bouffe
et après boffo je sens que je sais sur
12 aux coupures et
3 aussi
gérer vie mais j'ai pas vu mais je veux
dire alireza qu'il a dans les fichiers
juste ga je vous prends parce que ça
c'est pour la peine
salah très dangereux en fait
[Musique]
et dans son fichier
sur chaque page a pas de grosses écrit
aussi
j'ai pas j'arrive pas à jauger à son
visage si réfléchi ou pas mais voici
faut 2,5 tenait tempo mp au
secours au secours de nos régions
fait mal en fait
et de dire qui va gagner la première
partie 1 ils disent qu'il est maintenant
à plus de 8 je l'avais annoncé un il
était nommé dans des favoris duda
félicitations et les stations je suis
plutôt contente
alors dans ces cas là
cette partie d'aujourd'hui en quelque
sorte des warm à puiser dedans est en
quelque sorte
bise à boire en force de voir ma pièce
jointe au rapport mais rapport à 5
quasiment terminée en fait si peur comme
ça aujourd'hui
plus
il peut juste explosé en fait il peut
finir à moins 4 ou moins cinq un tournoi
comme celui-là
radjabov il doit pas être bien ce qu'il
peut avoir tout un pays qui est très
contente de celle à quoi la hongrie
à l'unanimité que
les lieux
dix minutes
il faut écrire on a des chiffres la
nationalité en scène
moins bavard mais on commence quand même
après dix coups seulement dans les
candidats richard importe étaient déjà
éliminés de la course au titre pourquoi
faut 2,5 mais la hausse ne veut rien et
c'est là bas vous a répondu à cette
question de jeu parce que les réserves
suis bien au stream et donc il suit elle
est à l'être nos recommandations de la
voiture lorsqu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
on a senti se fait chier encore non
regarde il dit [ __ ] qu'est ce que ces
longues contre intel comme lui quoi à
ces pénibles comment cette fois-ci quoi
bon bain sont chiés comment cette fois
ci comme en fait si ali reza gagner
aujourd'hui et on en est encore loin
quand même mais ainsi rapporté radjabov
perdent on a déjà quasiment deux joueurs
réellement éliminé de la course ouais
vraiment éliminer en fait sauf cas et
c'est très
rock et damman 8e tempo il va faire
par contre une fois en un peu moins de
se permettre de taper fort sur le point
de russie si jamais et puis voir les
réactions peut-être
sa vache marc
pigeon salines ces dames 1 8 dames ces
deux il faut prend 1,3 et tu as déjà et
humains dans ce faux bond girl est sûre
je lançais à 5 1,4 à 3,2 parce que ça va
aller très vite ratio d'amuser l'opinion
a surtout c'est assez facile que vous
avez une perte de fond
ça c'est facile à fait assez face aux
iles le pion de cette dame is to soul en
fait
on retient pas s'accroche en tout cas
pour le moment encore il est pas
décramponner va avoir un moment
difficile à passer
par contre moralement pour pour elle
pour radjabov aussi ça mon avis ça va
être très dur si par la première avec
les blancs parce que ça
détruit complètement son approche du
tournoi lui qui jouait en contre avec
les blancs pour essayer de survivre et
peut égaler une partie en compte six
paires aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
dramatique pour sa feuille de route à
vélo sa loi aux abeilles sa loi aux iem
à mon avis il peut vraiment se barrer en
fait
à a
atteint mais qu'est ce que tu fous il
les mettra pas les droits mais c'est pas
correct et on vous savez une r1 60 11
aussi il avoué au moins un an oui la
feuille je vois par dell j'ai le droit
c'est grâce à côté non mais tu dois
marque une seule envie c'est de barrer
en fait je pense si tu perds cette
partie pour lui non non non c'est une
obligation morale de rester tu veux dire
vous de ce paris lorsque paraît bien se
marrer
[Rires]
on m'a dit qu'il s'est divorcé il s'est
remarié c'est ça ouais exact il s'est
marié avec une fille qui est d'une
dynastie des actrices et chanteuses
chanteuse d'opérateurs
azéri aussi ou
[Musique]
moscovite il habite à moscou où tu sais
les l'habitat mon secours depuis un bon
moment
depuis j'ai pas au moins trois mois
peut-être plus vaste voir des fois non
jamais
je suis trop tranchants dans leurs
propos tu sais
quand il est ami avec des gens un peu
plus tranchant que tour à
voile
il a mis avec des gens très tranchant
donc dans ma vie tu devrais arriver il
est très pote avec arias qui n'ont été
menés tout le monde le sait en fait
donc gré dans ma vie tu devrais arriver
c'est le coup le plus logique ça doit
être encore la prépa ou alors il
connaissait jusqu'à cavaliers f4 et
tours 1 1 et par le coup mais il sait
que turin ce mauvais pas laissé le temps
à ces mauvais ouais
cheyrou va appuyer sur le bouton berzerk
alors le bouton à elle été con que ça
peut être ici c'est qu'ils ont plusieurs
fois et parce que l'autre est parti aux
toilettes il a fait son coup très vite
maintenant radjabov wes un point qu'il
veut pas au littoral et du coup il a pas
de son coup mbda il est né à thiès mais
je déguste comme point que tu veux
partir tollé donc je vous prends mon cou
et tu pars aux toilettes et oui voilà
oui c'est un poker toile et east et
cheklam toi est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est pas la pokerface mais la piste est
sale et que tu veux pisser des regards
il s'assoit non je devais tout moment un
bon moment
les streamer le public et tout le monde
comprend ce qui se passe maintenant en
fait ce qui se passe une autre piste
et regarde c'est bien pour ça qui tient
les mains bien basse
au moins aux yeux pourquoi cette torture
la torture espagnols
comme tu sais dans les rues ou lopez
parce que c'est un madrid léa torture
espagnol est ce qu'il ya des joueurs qui
ont déjà à pisser dans une bouteille
pendant leur parti j'ai entendu une
histoire beaucoup beaucoup plus grave
que celle là mais malheureusement j'ai
aucun droit de les recompter parce que
c'était pas l'histoire de pi c'est
[Rires]
pas possible
et l histoire est vraie parce que j'ai
comme citoyen culma m'a été racontée par
les victimes la victime est
terrible ah ouais il a fait quoi il
abandonné là continue il a continué et
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'à moi j'ai
rien compris je passais par la salle et
oui il m'a dit tout le monde était très
joli tir parce que personne n'avait
compris et ils ont après semblant qu'il
n'avait pas vu mais 'quand' à vue sauf
moi sauf toi ouais
il a perdu la partie où il a sauvé au
moins ça crève les la gagner et le
gagner
écoutez mais eux il a gagné il est vrai
mode don't cry 4
n'essayez pas de la sorte on peut dire
que l'expression se chier dessus est
fausse
gj en numéro huit grands maîtres en très
très fort très fort
l'adversaire 3 russie dans tout le monde
le connaît ici
[Rires]
et d'ailleurs je sais pas comment ça que
c'est pas parti sur l'internet ou
suspicion à un croyant réseau social je
sais pas
mais écoutez mais à part 2 2 les
réflexions qui on voit on vient d'écrire
là maintenant je sais pas de quoi elle
pointe sinon parce que la part de damas
huit je vois pas d'un coup fiable
peut-être alors les techniques telles
que eux ils voient la réponse de bercy
et il faut donc faire les mitraillettes
partir tout de suite son deuxième gain
vient aussi ya aussi autre chose quand
même d'importance et que c'est son
premier coup aux candidats en réalité
pardon c'est son premier coup le coup
qui va jouer maintenant c'est son
premier coup à lui aux candidats
prendre son elio donc elle doit donc
célébrée à l'euro
et plus je crois que c'était topalov qui
avait joué une partie avait une longue
préparent leurs 24 25 coups vous lis des
parties entre les deux est le premier
coup il sort de la prépa il fait une
grosse gaffe et il a dit j'ai fait une
faute parce qu'en fait jouer le coup qui
me paraissait évident alors que quand tu
as une prépa assez longue et que t'es
pas à rentrer dans la partie après
encore une heure et demie de jeu c'est
bien de prendre 10 15 minutes
juste pour commencer à calculer et
chauffée respaud cas pour pas que tu
amants se chauffe pour se chauffer
exactement peut-être c'est ce qu'il est
en train de faire ici juste deux ans
dans ce cas là c'est incroyable à quel
point mais les soviétiques ouais bah il
émane très mature où les soviétiques ne
se porte pas si mauvais les pelures
soviétique soviétique quoi
c'est ce qu'on appelle de la maturité
[Musique]
parce qu'un non ça c'est un bon signe
bien sûr parce que la scène nationale
c'est pas cohérent
c'est pas évident maçonnage assommage de
telle chose pourrait même pour passer
par son esprit il s'assied sur ses mains
ouais ouais ça c'est une très bonne
technique quand vous êtes trop impulsif
à l'air pur c'est une très très bonne
technique de ce soir comme ça c'est ce
qui au bout de vie nick a appris à
offrir à terme en off que ton pote grand
maître a essayé de faire dans le design
mais ça n'a pas trop marché
c'est même pas un pote juste quelqu'un
que je connais il m'a raconté cette
histoire parce que il m'a dit tu sais ce
que c'est passé comme dépassée par la
scène
judy page où ses patins et elsa et non
mais
ce n'est qu'une partie de l'iceberg
visible d'ailleurs comment dire est bien
en français halberg avec une partie
visible de l'iceberg ce n'est que la
partie visible de l'iceberg
vie du philosophe oui
tout cas ils calculent c'est sûr qu'il
adam 1,8 d'ailleurs j'ai dit ça sur un
stream mais peut-être projets n'ont pas
été là ces qui a à l'époque firent usa a
été
l'eau la ville le village plutôt l'eau
plus au sud de l'ex union soviétique
et j'ai visité ce village il y avait un
tournoi d'échecs ça a été un oasis dans
un désert
désert le donc les villes ou plutôt le
village le plus au sud de l'union
soviétique
xb
virus appelé d'ailleurs
j'ai de très bons souvenirs donc j'ai
bien son nom malheur pour c'est pour
cette raison-là
s'annonce comme un tir aux à se dire le
nom de fil rouge à ce que je sais qu en
cyrillique vous vendredi pizza
est composé de l'enam à lombers savio
forcément à dire quelque chose il faut
chiquillo mais c'est fort c'est que ça
veut dire quelque chose parce que déjà
par exemple les normes de leur foi en
veulent toujours quelque chose ils
disent que le warm boy a perdu son
avantage
bien sûr alors il veut où
il veut aux joueurs fou à 4 encaissés le
pion sur ceux ci c'est que c'est comme
ça qu'il pense qu'il va gagner cette
partie bien sûr les noirs doivent
répondre f5 parce qu'il faut faire
quelque chose ce monde en 9 août yu
positionnement n'est foutu si on criait
pas je sais par les gens disent que
c'est quand même encore russe de hockey
et 5 par contre f3 je sais quoi je vois
pas quelque chose mais qui viennent
explique mans où il a fait quoi je vois
toujours pas de la fête 27 x 4
mon vol qf6 égale
gérer flop le tofu 3 qui viennent
peut-être je crois toujours pas quels
costumes
à danser quoique je vois rien
à
où
c'est beau je dirais
sans doute
donc alors pas d'autre terme pour 3
après
5 donc c'est pas clair on va faire un
petit tour on nous dit que le hb non
l'appel le h hikaru
mais c'est pas parce que certains rien
non c'est parce que c'est sa lettre je
ne sais pas
ils disent que les noirs sont mieux ici
lors ddcs et noir sont mieux
mais peut-être que c'est long au
par contre il est vrai qu'il peut être
le temps matériaux bouffer
dans mes trois ans vise deux pions donc
je crains que vous les deux
je sais pas qu'il s'y coller au dos
peut-être même collé de encore les trois
quarts
les 2 3 d'ailleurs quatre
exemples ce point est ce que ça peut
être mieux pour le noir d'être un des
ces français 8 ans moi ok milieu
vraiment pourquoi ni comment mieux
et indigne
il
n'a pas poussé b5 il a donc
ignoré son cavalier daily news - bien
que tout à la mairie valverde 6 mais
elle veut aller sur des sites ok moi je
mon auto fait un truc on sait pas tour
de 8 parce que toute façon c'est obligé
plus qu'avant les c4
où il est vrai c'est ce que important
c'est que tu veux tourner en coller des
six est sûr que les 7 et a toujours
collé à saint cloud saas que hyper
chiant puis autre intérêt des pulsions
non ok il est mieux quoi je ne sais pas
à quel point peut-être en fait ce que je
prévois en étant incapable de calculer
en regardant jouer comme ça absolument
je pense que ce concours très important
maintenant c'est que escaut né pauvre
jours précisément maintenant très très
précisément parce que peut-être si ils
voulaient coup lambda que peut-être ça
va devenir trop quoi
ok cavaliers ses sept
[Musique]
as qu'il veut pas faire de russie jeu 5
bourbourg tour agissent d'abord 5
une grosse question je sais que
d'habitude les joueurs chinois n'ont pas
peur d'autres trucs mais alors dit déjà
mieux pour les noirs après mais j'ai pas
vu avant c'est-à-dire de russie ces jeux
seul comprend ça marche comment
badiou bouge ici où çà
ou là non c'est sûr qu'ils se montrent
trop d'espacés c'est sûr que c'est ma
came as trop d'espacé tu as taxe c'est
toujours moi
écoutez je commence demande qui était un
petit peu
parce que les victoires donnent pause
les dernières choses dans le monde que
je
retourne sur anyresa ouais
il réfléchit toujours après tour lent
ce qui aura un autre coup qui nous
aurait échappé mais je vois pas trop
d'un v8 ça paraît vraiment logique hein
damas huit c'est vraiment logique
à djouba tempo vrai mais bon au bout
d'un moment il faut aussi ralentir un
moment pour un coût de 1
je comprends pas le ku'damm à 8 bat
c'est pour taper sur la diagonale
bêtement un
pour se mettre en batterie avec le fou
étape et on a déjà le cavaliere 4 qui
tape sur g2 le fou des cinq qui tape on
veut mettre la dame à 8 rajouter une
pièce pour attaquer et renforcer la
pression bon menacera déjà fou prend 1,4
en fait si la dame est à 8
donc
c'est juste pour renforcer
la pression quoi
c'est assez logique en fait
en réalité c'est assez logique
il a 45 minutes d'avancé ou qui peut se
permettre oui après c'est plus jouer
vite pour enlever du temps à
l'adversaire qu'autre chose en réalité
c'est plus cet esprit là en fait c'est
pas jouer vite pour conserver son temps
c'est vraiment jouer vite pour que
l'adversaire n'en est pas
en tout cas pas assez
pour pour réaliser les bons coups ok
j'ai un peu regardé avec les turbines à
ce que j'ai à dire c'est comme au quai
damas où il doit sûrement faire bien
mais sinon bien sûr ils pensent que de
terreur à j 5
c'est que d'ailleurs les permis de
gagner des jeux à côte il ya deux ans et
sur h3 un truc al-akwaa suite au rejet
8e
ouais donc tandis qu'au hockey d'amaury
tout à fait un autre univers
pascoe kheddam ces deux fois 3 ici les
points joue pour
contre attaquer comme kovalev 5 et qui a
un gros bordel commence je vois pas de
trop de risques pour les noirs mais bel
et bon sang qu'est aussi quoi pression
compliqué elle était bien sûr un
collègue sigeif de mars est mat et ici
au lieu de cela en fait alors quand les
jeux 6
4 qui arrive aux phobiques à terrassa
qu'est ce que le début mais je ne peux
pas votre trop fatigué avec mes valises
turbine est ça dépend si ça arrive pas
en fait turbiner c'que
j'veux 5 dont un point c'est tout bon je
sais mais mais oui le sabot à amay l
ordinateur dont on voyait sur la même
chose c'est pas un des gens ils ont
enfin si on avait les évaluations de
l'ordinateur et les coûts ce serait je
crois que relate à une meilleure
turbines bah écoutez plus du monde à une
turbine turbine comme le mien quoi
c'est pas parce qu'on vous dit qu'un
coup est possible qu'il donne pas
l'avantagé à l'adversaire en fait
s'il faut aller raisin oublier que ça
lui de jouer non ça ça ça ça va ça fait
combien ton se fait déjà presque une
demi heure de réflexion nandja 20
minutes vingt bonnes minutes déjà sur ce
coup
c'est son premier réel coût 1 dans ces
candidats
se croit la turbine boulade
je me demande quand deux fois sur 100 tu
vas changer de coût entre le monde tu
réfléchis samedi vide celui du rififi 30
minutes souvent tu vous même comme je
sais pas moi quand je mets beaucoup
réfléchir je peux vraiment changé je
crois beaucoup au jeu s'ils jouent pas
un truc après 10 15 milliards de mails y
ait des raisons pourquoi vous
réfléchissez
personnes et prenant le plus souvent
vous réfléchissez quand vous voulez
calculé au bond et puis frère par
exemple les mitraillettes et souvent si
votre adversaire à un manque de temps
que c'est pas le cas encore à jabot fois
beaucoup de temps encore mais souvent
quand votre adversaire à un manque de
temps les meilleurs des méthodes c'est
les mitraillettes et une fois vous
faites une série du coup privé puis
votre propre et encore pour faire la
deuxième épreuve c'est d'ailleurs le
plus haut
le plus aux chiens pour l'adversaire
pour plusieurs raisons
la première raison parce que une série
de coups sortent et deuxième raison
excusez moi moi je reviens toujours sur
les questions de toilette oui vous avez
pas être temps de vous détendre
quand un joueur au but d'appuyer sur la
pendule il n'y pas prévenu parle arbitre
je crois pas non pardon ça m'est jamais
arrivé quand quelqu'un oublie d'art et
d'appuyer sur la pendule espace rien non
je pense que personne
ne doivent pas voulu dire non cet avis
quoi sauf autre pote qui va par exemple
tu après votre pied et offert un petit
si
il mitraille c'est quoi c'est enchaîner
les coups un holà c'est une métaphore
il faut qu'il trouve le damel temps mais
damas huit c'est le coup le plus facile
de la position c'est le premier coup
auquel on pense à on en sait c'est les
lignes que je montrais qu'il est en
train de calculer oui je joue toujours
ouais mais c'est sur
moi par contre j'ai ticket tout à
l'heure un petit peu avec leurs 10 100 %
au lieu de fou de 5000 et détroit aurait
pu permettre que les airs sans aucun
risque si il a choisi est un peuple aux
fondations coup de collier 3 mai ce qui
s'écrit à guilers et l'elysée et il est
public euros aujourd'hui belliqueux
belliqueux il veut pas juste venu avec
le noirmont
pourquoi faire en fait ouais on
trentaine ouais donc un seul coup at il
vraiment beaucoup même si on a pu le
comprendre même à van damme à 8 juin
damas où est quand même l'autre va
revenir tout de suite parce que l'été
par luan et donc il est bien
suivi son adversaire à gérer aulas qui
se lève pour la première fois et qui va
sauver pour la première fois s'est
longuement il a déjà été debout mais là
on sent qu'il a besoin de se détendre de
se dégourdir les jambes après cette
longue réflexion et ça fait peur du
temps là timour ça fait déjà 30 seconds
rôles étaient pas là il n'était pas là
ça fait déjà 30 secondes de 6,7 sur wii
jeu télé à quoi j'aurais été là quoi
ouais bah écoutes je serai là pardon
écoute c'est étonnant je regarde combien
de temps il va il va mettre pour revient
ça fait déjà 40 au lieu de doha jazz sur
l'échiquier on voit que le but donner
pour passer il a l'air confiant n'est
point
au wip oisiens pas il y aura t il
en est complètement sûr connaissant le
loustic cavayé a cédé et le retourner
après 56 contre 5 55 secondes il a mis
55 est-ce qu'il va pas le regretter
jusque-là fournissait beaucoup parce que
sur car ce tournoi final rendu plus de
1% sont en 2 % de son temps important
c'est impardonnable c'est vraiment
énorme et je dame ces deux tempos
évidemment
et là on devrait voir fou prend 1,3 et
cavaliers voilà en quelques longs de
l'otan qui ont offert aux avoirs m pour
retourner
donc
quinzaine de corps ça revient beaucoup
plus vite que tu alireza ça met la
pression
qu'est ce que les plus jeunes comme
il savait que c'était dame ses deux bras
il devrait jouer fou prend à 3
rapidement il s'est embarqué dans cette
variante avec damas huit il n'a pas trop
le choix ici
si non il va ya voir tour au 3 août
prochain et savent à blinder le cheval
f3 le pion à 3 la case d3 et la casse b4
au passage alors que prendra trois ça
permet de gagner un pion de contrôler la
case b4 d'envoyer le pion à c'est
clairement le coup ici
cinq et il est bien sapé ses routes déjà
on voit hikaru qui passe
chemise à carreaux
ce sera incroyable ainsi car ou gagner
aujourd'hui avec les noirs contre
caruana gaz espère qu'ils n'ont quand
même
de toute manière yeux mes amis mais à
quoi ça sert si elle se qualifie c'est
contre 4,5 dans tout les cas dans ces
lieux en square un million 3 quoi mais
messi carles scène joue pas
non au contraire où il voit jeu parce
que c'est un ricain parce que ça serait
bien dotées parce que si tu as un square
millions contre 3 pourquoi pas faire le
score peu millions le coup droit mais
non ça va être juste un match
ce que ça peut ressembler un castor
short
plus ou moins it will be shot matabiau -
est-ce que tu as compte appeler souvent
mais les gueules des carreaux quand ils
jouent contre personne
non batta l'impression qu'il devient
deux fois moins qu'un mois déjà et le
poids énorme bataille l'impression que
quoi
tu te crois dans un conte d'andersen
quoi j'ai
donc y réfléchir je suis étonné qu'ils
envoient pas après une si longue
réflexion vous prend à 3 tempo
un peu bizarre là sa gestion du temps
ok bon joueur français
au bo bobo bon ok il a bien sûr preview
d'un pseudo hélas déjà pris cette
décision dont claire maintenant et je
pense pas que le voit trop tarder
il a l'air détendu mais je sais pas il
ya un pas deux
pas il n'a pas le droit de s'y
concentrer que possible apprécierez les
coupes poste de la romance music
mon ami je serais ce que vous voyez pour
moi
messina qu'arrive deuxième m'a glissé
capable de jouer le match juste pour
faire chier hikaru
c'est pour ça que je le vois pas ne pas
jouer en fait il ya trop de cas de
figure où je tiens à vous rappeler qu'il
ya jeanne 9 à 8 ans et caro a donné
l'interview à une pièce où il a dit à
nic historique au contexte un endroit le
plus dangereux c'est incroyable je peux
vous dire déjà c'est rigolo et je peux
vous dire aussi mes amis comme
parmi les plus grands joueurs de chèques
de telles phrases s'oublie jamais ouais
ça je peux vous le garantir je sais de
quoi je parle vous dites ça et c'est mal
placé et vous ne pouvez vous pouvez
rayer toute l'ariège et cciqa ou qui
avait dix à propos de magnus way i di
cristo le coc contexte moins cher ma
charge
et d'être historique au contexte les one
très présente sur le stand du maroc en
chine m
pour le spectateur je suis le seul à
représenter un danger pour un magnus
carlsen en étant ils étaient menés 10-0
n'en aurait vraiment eu cette excellence
c'était assez comique
je crois que c'est celui qui avait le
score le pire en plus juste le pire
très précis je ne sais pas si
pire parce que celui qui a joué le plus
de parties contre un ep il a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de défaites
jamais compris pourquoi il avait dit ça
d'ailleurs
combat pour l'europe
mais probablement pas oui
10 juin de regarder il ya 14 à 1 pour
magnus en classique 26 nuls ouais c'est
vrai que c'est assez assez violent qui
est votre seule partie contre une seule
celle de l'agro ben pourquoi pas sorti
cette phrase
[Rires]
le contexte historique et pq
mais rsa c'est un sens incroyable
surtout que je pense qu'ils y croyaient
pas vraiment lui-même à cette phrase
est toujours c'est hypocrite mais après
est obligé de faire un peu de langue de
bois lorsque tu répond aux interviews
sportive j'ai envie de dire
combien je veux dire jusqu'en
le mieux c'est que quand tu es capable
de décoration à la mort ahmad ali et
puis tout fouet à la main ahmed ali oui
écoutez mes amis je vous dresse pourtant
des menottes vas-y vlad on nous dit au
moment où tu pars que
12 ans aurait perdu tout son avantage
contre richard rapporte
alors ça c'est loin d'être évident
c'est loin d'être évident la position
reste complexe mais c'est vrai que
lecavalier réussi à se rediriger vers
des 6 mai restent encore les deux pions
faible c'est pas il n'est pas encore
sorti
du bois richard apportent
leur donne quoi ils donnent genre un
truc comme cavalier des six pouces et 4
il a fait froid c'est cette
quelques cavaliers arrivant c4 est ce
qu'on a le temps de faire du cavalier b6
pour essayer d'échanger les chevaux mais
cavaliers à 5 et ce cavalier a toujours
pas de case il va se reprendre un pion
b3 il va se faire
couper toutes les oreilles
il est plus plus que van gogh end mais
sur roy c'est set
il a joué sous ses quatre aussi tempo
alors il a l'idée de jouer vous prend
ici c'est et de détruire la structure de
pions adverse sur flu g4 il va faire f3
qui est un coup utile donc on s'attend à
fou prend ses quatre cavaliers france et
f6 peut-être fou et 3
mais ouais non ça reste dur cavalli b6
cavaliers à 5 la position reste très
difficile
pour
[Musique]
pour rapporte après c'est pas gagné
encore un mais mais la position reste
complexe
et difficile à défendre caruana
contre nakamura on avait dit avec la que
la position était
très très compliqué et beaucoup de
choses pouvaient encore arrivé
bon là le roi noir va aller se cacher
probablement ses huit peut-être la tour
va venir en dn cavaliers en ckt aussi
des f4 qui peuvent partir position très
incertaines tout peut arriver encore
dans cette partie car ou qui est bien
bien sortie de l'ouverture
nepomniachi contre ding l'irene
donc on a comme prévu ce cavalier qui
est venu en c4 pour taper sur la case
des 6 et ian qui a placé la tour ont
aussi su une tour en 6e ranger qui
contrôle la casse des six et qui
interdit aux cavaliers de jaillira sur
cette case où il taperait sur beaucoup
de points névralgiques des noirs donc la
tour et si ce contrôle tous rêvent d un
pour venir renforcer la menace sur la
case des 6es cavaliers des cinq pour
couper la connexion de la tour avec la
casse des 6es et dingli rennes qui a
joué tour des cadres donc il vient sans
prendre maintenant aux options e4 et
l'ordinateur semble aimer les noirs
après g5 si on prend g5 dame pranger
5-fu prend 2,4 pour prendre quatre tours
prend 1,4 et d'alger si cela pointe qui
vient jouer sur le cloud à ce genre là
c'est vraiment compliqué un cavalier d2
pour renforcer et cavalli m6 et sur g3
le problème c'est qu'il ya dame prend g3
et on n'a jamais droit et enfin à cause
de foisches trois matchs donc position
très compliqué là encore mais
l'ordinateur sommes vraiment aimé les
noirs après g5 ou difficile à jouer mais
ça peut être un coup important dans ce
tournoi
6-6 nepomniachi réussi à gagner avec les
noirs contre dingli rennes il se placera
déjà de nouveau comme un favori de ce
tournoi des candidats et on voit qu'il a
l'air de calculer il a l'air confiant le
joueur qui joue à ce tournoi sous
l'égide de la fidh
la position semble
favorable au noir après une courte
analyse
le coup j'ai 500 m en revanche le seul
coup un pur jeu davantage s'ils jouent
quelque chose de plus tranquille comme
tours à huit pour défendre les blancs
pourrait jouer tour a eu un et après
j'ai cinq tours prend des cinq qui on
prend des cinq tours prend des cinq pour
jouer sur la 5eme ranger semble
suffisant pour les blancs pour prendre à
minima légalité et peut-être même plus
parce que le roi peut devenir faible et
que cette tour en d5 soutenu par le
cavalier c4 est vraiment très forte
donc né paul acquis un coût très
important à jouer ça peut être le coup
de la partie et on va retourner chez
notre joueur français ali reza qui après
damas huit dames c'est 2 continue à
réfléchir gestion du temps un petit peu
questionnable un côté français il a pris
à 21 ans une minute pour jouer damas
huit et et sur dame ces deux ça fait
déjà un petit quart d'heure 1 qu'il est
qu'ils en réflexion joueurs français
d'origine iranienne alireza firoud déjà
qui fêtera ses 19 ans demain
et qui en train de réfléchir à fou prend
à trois cavaliers mg5 comme le suggérait
vlad
ci commence par un coup comme tours b 8
les blancs vont mettre cette tour en
hausse 3
et défendre leur troisième rangée
d'ailleurs après foix iii a partout
agressif conquois college 5 les douanes
pour un coût aussi à ces pratiques
construit
quelque chose comme bas mot 3 pour
chasser le
et maintenant je sais pas alain deux
tours
plus tôt et la tour 2
c'est compliqué ça aussi moyens au lieu
d' homme quand les jeux 6 devrait offrir
qui viennent aussi le cadre
d'un no 4 la moquette tours 4 collecte
de sang et puis comme ça tu te sens
assez têtue bouge très vite à
gagnoa de yako l'histoire je vais jamais
gagné ça ne mange pas de pain mais par
contre je vois pas comment tu peux
perdre sa main plusieurs
si les browns ont pas échanger les taux
et les bois dormant charge pour le tour
par contre il ya un truc un peu
alarmiste
oui puisqu'il ya la remise souci c'est
qu'elle est rezaï vient de prendre des
risques pour rien si c'est pour faire ça
possible
mayer si c'est le cas le plus important
maintenant c'est de ne pas regretter
mais bon je t'ai toujours se pose là
oui mais faut mannheim et mais sans
réfléchir à ce que tu as fait au coup
presque regretter est-ce que tu as
parfois pas dans la partie c'est la pire
des choses qui peut terminer je sais je
sais ça peut ça peut coûter cher
plus qu'une demi heure d'avancé 1 il a
mis la manger une demi heure là même un
peu plus sur ces deux coups
ça va flécher duda 12 ha qui garde un
avantage après s'ils rapportent s'en
sort ce sera quand même du bol parce que
ce qui fait c'est très logique
damas huit étapes sur quatre mais un
beau savoir aussi re
pourquoi est-ce que à part de vouloir
gagner aujourd'hui pourquoi aussi
fair use a pris des risques en jouant un
jour un flot de sang que 21 coups bien
sûr ça peut être expliquer aussi par
l'esthétique oui parce que le fou sur
2,5 le cavaly suricate et la dame sur à
huit c'est beau
un peu pagny c'est beau ça tape fort oui
et donc pour certains
artistes chez qui aiment la beauté d'un
tel truc est irrésistible une fois et le
voit et lille vont quoi en plus t'as le
fou qui peut venir un peu attaqué sur
cette diagonale dans l'impression de
contrôler juste toutes les cases de
l'échiquier
en quelque sorte
ça réfléchit en fait la leçon on est un
peu dans le moment creux de la partie et
eddy si on va dire une demi-heure une
heure ça va s'emballer
je pense on est un peu dans le don de
temps mort entre guillemets sur toutes
les parties là entre 1h30 1h45 de jeu et
3h30 et les peaux qui a pas à trouver il
y avait un g5 donne un grand avantage
année paumé mais il l'a raté vlad à la
dubai
dubai et tu peux souplesse jeter un coup
d'oeil rapide sur mac à parce que
quelqu'un a écrit qu' au
il a fait une connerie la totale
et comme je crois aux spectateurs je
voudrais bien vous il ne faut pas
souvent de la merde
à il leur ferait alors
la fin truc très logique quand même
très logique et je sais pas d'eau
de telles évaluations aussi grosses que
ça pour les bons parce que comme ça
c'est pas évident de comprendre pourquoi
pourquoi est ce qu'après ce projet
quatre saisies libre ans
si mieux que ça pour un internement
c'est pas évident encore non mais là
mais c'est que quand même intéressant
qu'il n'a pas voulu mettre son cavalier
sur des trois mois sur des deux ou deux
parents sont des gamins moins bien pour
ceux qui sur un an
mais pour aller sur des trois plus tard
mais je sais pas mais [ __ ] c est
peut-être passé comme ça
ah oui mais f5 et toujours bien défendu
youtube de terre il veut garder l'option
donc je collais c4
parce que peut-être review les positions
l'affaiblissent du roi abdel aziz pour
ses cadres bosse et qu'on voit c'est pas
dangereux parce que dans les positions
où vous avouer d'eau tour d'un autre
doute dourdan de loin le plus important
c'est les écuries du roi pelé plus que
tout le reste les structures de pions
tout le reste ouais
il a joué à six pour préparer j'ai 500
d'après leur dit c'est
notre petit bras en beauté mais je sens
que quand même plus efficace comme
auteur tout penaud agissent que casas 6
est libre pour la tour
et puis en plus une idée c'est peut être
tout reprend des cinq ici en fait et
d'ailleurs ça c'est très
clair
que ça va être très tendu c'est un coup
à un coût très important d'ailleurs tu
savais qu il en fait son nom se
prononcent pas comme tu me plairait mais
comme disent les jeunes oui je sais
ça va jouer encore c'est pas là non pas
de r
je pense les chinois donc ça veut dire
que pour orgue riche succès j'échoue
ji choi jai-chul g shock du coup je suis
bon je dis
[Rires]
donc ça continue à réfléchir écoutant on
n'a plus grand chose à faire que
d'attendre et joie
je m'en
réjouis au lieu de vraiment le doit à
nos rapports orageux s'est trompé non
non non et vous quelles mains et doigts
je
dois jouer je mangerai dois-je
2015 ou
vous passez par la case pas ce jour il
cage ou non d'un cas joumaa n'a qu'un
gars de cash profs
non non pas de r tu dis oui enfin je
prends ce
janot
noté repris chance
pour la france
en fait on sait pas vraiment
non je ne sais pas vraiment pas ça en
fait ça le truc et il est patent que les
rennais les ting tings association ça
c'est certain
[Rires]
à
vérifier cette information ce qu'on
connaît quelqu'un qui ferait s'il vous
plaît oui je peux pas appeler à ma
copine m'a aidée par le chinois
parfaitement donc dit nous s'il vous
plaît si quelqu'un comme les réponses
mais ça commence à m'inquiéter la
l'iresa valade parce que quand même ça
fait déjà trois quarts d'heure sur damas
huit fou prend 1,3 alors je comprend un
skill en bête mais ça commence à faire
beaucoup
voyez le coeur
non madame
boursica même me quel était ce une
qualité bouffe le cubain
l'église une gaffe de diglee rennes
encore
dam des deux
je pense que la position est juste trop
compliqué pour comprendre ce qu'est une
gaffe ce qui est pas une gaffe mais
visuellement c'est un peu bizarre de
voir le tour des hoquets un truc que tu
erres élevé au pourrait alors pas avec
la tour jean toussaint vont avec la
table pour du piano pour dix mois elle
ce qu'il veut faire
[Musique]
mais du coup c'est pas vraiment cloud
est
juste michelin qui arrive
oui mais ça aussi inquiet pour
[Musique]
mais elle doit être plutôt pour un fou
ricard ou mischa
pas clair je pense un
n'oublie pas
il faut à elle et disputant chez
américain
il a un frère aussi je croyais qu'il y
au japon au canada je crois je suis pas
sûr fois demandé à des spécialistes de
la vie d'hikaru
je sais juste que son père était mort
mais non mais là je sais pas ce qui fait
aller rezaï ce qui va jouer à temps mal
mètres en k mais il se passe quoi en
fait c'est difficile de comprendre
pourquoi ils envoient pas fou prend 1,3
plus vite
malaga rabeux les mouvements les petits
mouvements de son corps
mais il est bloqué comment s'appelait
se balance
il se balance
ouais la balançoire mais juste balance
ils voient pas le pion en un
non c'est difficile c'est difficile
d'interpréter la ce ralentissement est
sale usap qui est dans le chatt salut à
toi c'est difficile à interpréter parce
qu'ils jouaient vite il jouer pour
mettre la pression sur la pendule de
rajab afij ou eh bien ils jouaient les
coûts précis et là tout d'un coup sur
une séquence de coûts qui paraît assez
simple
il réfléchira forcément il réfléchit
plus loin il vous prend à 3 mais
quel est l'intérêt au final y ait
quelque chose que j'aime il ya quelque
chose qui le gêne lancé sur regarde
regarde le visage de la tête comme ça
qui
je comprends sa plus grande
préoccupation maintenant non c'est pas
de risque et perdre non non c'est parce
que vous a dit me revoir lui dire après
les piétements c'est ce que nous animons
police
à qui le procureur ah ouais c'est ça son
sa plus grande peur matin
je le comprends
ouais ça réfléchit sexe à calcul sec
mais ouais il est gêné et ça se voit
dans son langage corporel haïssent ils
changent beaucoup de positions et on
sent qu'il est pas
c'est pas confortable pour lui
regarde on a déjà regardé en fait la
guerre d'algérie c'est séparément une
dinguerie cet avenir et g5 un g6 h4
phobie 4 h 5 fu au carré collé aux
quatre collèges 4h 6 l et noir vont
récupérer la tour - comme quoi il ya le
pion alpha 0 par contre c'est très loin
de thermal parce que le corps et les
noirs et les abris et en plus il ya un
an de plus mais peut-être aussi dit que
dans ces cas là c'est l'autre qui
embarrasse du matos pour attaquer pas
l'inversé et peut-être ça aux gens cette
perspective là sûrement ça m'a parlé il
ya une demi heure
à
chercher autre chose mais y'a pas en
fait
y'a pas et ça c'est ça qui est
inquiétant c'est qu'en fait il peut
réfléchir
encore un long moment
il peut juger un coup à côté en fait
y'a pas de quoi côté ici je vais faire
tomber 8,3
[Musique]
et si j'ai moi je joue je crois
et pourquoi ça si fort que ça
dure comprenant
tour 3 juste rwanda comme l'info à 3 pt
ok
d'accord
et c'est ça qui va
alors dans ce cas là se vouer 2,3 et si
je bouffe sur fois toi
as tu bouges coli e
ah ouais d'accord donc te retrouves pas
dans ce que brooke et pour recalculer
une telle variante de reprendre
normalement un sixième de ce qu'on dit
tu as maxime qui nous dit il faut
prendre en main ces classes affaires et
ses peurs c'est ça le truc sans fait on
voit que ça le gêne cet avantage 6 il
n'a pas trop le choix
il n'a pas de bol quand même là je
trouve que
ça aurait pu beaucoup mieux marché que
ça oui mais c'est ce qu'elle a cherchés
tu l'as voulu tu l'as eu oui
si tu cherches la tempête
celui qui sème le vent récolte la
tempête oh hey
you and you can also
récolte ce que tu sèmes
mêmes nadja si ce qui en fait le plus
c'est que le jeu devient facile pour
hadjadj après fou prend à 3 ouais c'est
mal tombé en fait
et tour un été assez bien joué en
réalité vous disiez tout à l'heure que
c'était prix pas tout seul
très très loin c'était les prépas bien
sûr mais bien sûr nous on ne peut pas
juger où ça s'arrête en fait il avait
jusque là où s'arrête sa prépa aux
s'arrête
ce
qui sera prélevé après cavaliers detroit
c'était dans ces trois cas la somme
direct dans ce cas terme de sa part de
sa côte est l'histoire ces six nuls donc
la prépa elle était bien c'est juste que
après il a décidé de
il a décidé de jouer le bien et de
victimiser
prendre un peu de risques en fait ce
qu'espère ingerop dans ce tournoi que
ses adversaires prennent des risques et
qu'il les contres alors on était très
confiant parce qu'en plus il avait une
heure d'avancé à la pendule il semblait
savoir ce qu'ils faisaient et est en
réalité
oui savait pas trop et
non c'est bon c'est bon je sais petit
mist
ouais c'est c'est pas c'est pas une
bonne phase de jeu pour nous on était
beaucoup plus confiant à 16h30
qu'est ce que cette phrase veut dire
dans ce contexte qu on finit le vide où
commence le slip je sais contexte ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire est ce que
la grosseur du slip n'est pas lié à la
grosseur du bit quoi est-ce que c'est
pas la brioche qui est plus grosse que
la baguette
jeu vient d'adapter d'accord
je viens d'adapter
à l'énoncé
complexe et j'essaie de choper en fait
y'a aucune caméra où on voit le musée en
fait j'ai compris c'est tu vois même sur
le truc américain où ils sont a plus
évolué que nous
traite on voit jamais le musée quoi elle
ça fait autant de thèmes que
vous utilisez le terme népotisme globale
d'un dépôt
pas la partie la partie on est adams et
2 ça n'a pas bougé
on est la première connue monde non en
fait ne pas en prendre un point mais
comme le monde mais je peux vous dire
qu'en tentant de regarder le musée les
candidats sont surprenamment pas suivi
du tout surpris notamment négativement
tu vas y a que dix mille spectateurs sur
hikaru c'est autant que pour un title
tuesday ce qui fait quand même peur et
il n'y a que 26 mille huit cents
américains en sachant qu'avec toutes les
premières pages qu'ils ont partout c'est
vraiment peu
d'ailleurs ça veut dire que la hype des
échecs date ce n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle en fait ça veut dire que comme
je l'avais pressenti plus personne ne
s'intéresse aux échecs en faire donc je
suis habitué à ça mais que cancer dans
quelle mesure parce que je suppose à
madrid y a pas un mot 2 donc d'un kill
musée c'est
parce que
si c'est dans le musée prada c'est une
chose si c'est d'aller au musée de ramon
c'est une autre chose à nous dire où cos
réseau
alors que me ludique 25 me sur chaise
comme ouais surtout qui doit être en
première par rapport au prado sahara et
c'est extrêmement peu voilà s'auto
saint-thomas
s'assurant monter au fil de la compet je
pense ouais mais c'est vraiment
nettement moins que ce qu'on a eu vu un
y à il ya encore un an c est ce genre
divisé par trois ou quatre
c'est vraiment peu
dans ma huit dames ces deux
et ça bloque vraiment sûr pour ali reza
qu'est-ce qu'elle adore jouer sur mon
air quoi
et nous et nous 7005 va nous en fait
ouais non nous c'est pas mal en fait en
vrai mais comme toujours nous savons en
français bon l'important c'est que ça
reste populaire internationalement
c'est moins que je puisse rapidement
poussé à peu près pareil au début du
tournoi nous ça va monter c'est pour les
candidats à la phase aller c'est à peu
près c'était même - et ça va monter
petit à petit suivant les résultats donc
c'est assez correct
dong
donc dams et 2
ok mais il réfléchit pas quand même
quelques mois je suis je suppose je sais
pas moi ça m'inquiète vraiment parce que
quand tu passe autant de temps à jouer
un coup
d'ailleurs
sur 1,6 peut-être qu'ils viennent on
peut faire les mêmes choses durent 3 x 3
et quand les jeux simples
ça va pas du tout
c'est trop dur en fait
je suis en train de montrer un tas
variante
j'aime pas du tout quand un joueur à
réfléchir aussi longtemps suivant il
fait de l'agro souvent il fait faire un
gros coup de chiottes
surtout dans des positions aussi
compliqué c'est qu'il a raté un truc
dans il ya un truc qui le gêne dans vous
prend à 3 et qui va jouer autre chose
mais juste nous on sait que tous les
autres coûts vont pas
oui quelqu'un a demandé ce qu'ils
chantent 2 fait mal et pourquoi elles
sont affichées c'est pas la folie qui
qui a sponsorisé le tournoi sur herbe
semaine
si si c'est la même main donc c'est
l'infirmerie qui a alors sponsorisés
point d'être un truc de poker je suppose
et un moment donné donc de loin le plus
grand
de l'histoire des échecs ou les joueurs
de l'élite
comme jamais vu avant je connais des
honoraires avant le tournoi au jour
d'élite et c'était quelque chose en gros
dans un open
je lui retourne affirmé donc comme
souvent j'aime bien de vous raconter des
petites scènes je crois qu'ils avaient
un rapport avec pokerstars aussi
heureuse bien sûr j'espère pas dire de
bêtises mais je crois qu'ils avaient un
rapport avec pokerstars
donc ali reza qui commence à faire peur
d'ailleurs up pour ceux qui
s'intéressent
comme je parlais tout donc le chan big
family qui
assurent ils hoffman et un truc
intéressant sur une longue semaine ce
que j'ai lu que c'est un seul endroit au
monde du chat non parce que ouais à lui
le sauveur
j'ai voulu devant c'est parce que j'ai
pensé que si tu disais avant tu croirais
pas que je savais ça c'était pas facile
à savoir ouais c'était pas évident
j'ai préféré devancer pour voir
d'apparemment à la voile et le palacio
dos santos d'après leur site c'est un
lieu où il joue au fric mois pour les
loups fréquemment pour des événements
design et de mode
tournoi d'échecs et pourquoi mesure
est là mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ne
couvre en fait j'en suis si le loup
parce que c'est comme peut-être une
pièce de châteaux en france ou quoi je
sais les volumes sont bien
c est aussi généralement quand il ya des
défilés ou des conférences de presse
dans le luxe il aime bien louer des
endroits comme ça aux
gens pour louis vuitton genre de truc ce
que bien pour nous évitons mais pas top
pour un tournoi d'échecs
peut-être l'envers ce qui est top pour
un taux d'échec est pas top pour
louisville vol
mais comme dit que les poissons et c'est
plutôt un endroit style et qu'un musée
ouais
hein oui mais je ne sais pas quoi y
sommes il en train de rattraper il fait
plus que rattrapé radjabov encore la lgv
aurifères sont au coeur il va jouer mais
il n'a pas l'air content vu comment il
se tient les mains le coup a l'air de le
désespéré mais si la gestuelle et qu'est
ce que c'est un joueur de chacun c'est
carrément comment le joueur d'échecs le
plus fort sont
souvent dans les films en leur montrant
différemment maintenant si vous voulez
voir comment elles sont six joueurs
d'élite c'est pourquoi mon mothma
alireza
voilà des fous ça va quoi
mais c'est ça se voit que le coup qu'il
allait jouer c'est pas un coup qui lui
plaît ouais elle et riza arrête de
montrer autant des sentiments intérieurs
oui un peu en plus en plus haut mais pas
autant que ça qu il faut un peu caché
bas il faut se murmure qu'à main
il a pourtant montré une grande maturité
dans l'ouverture mais là il est il est
tombé
petit coup petit manque de réussite en
riant n'a aux échecs des fois le 's&p'
ont joui ça se passe très bien parfois
ça se passe moins bien
c'est un moment de moins bien pour ali
reza il faut finir par jouer un coup
façon vraiment si ça reflue rien de
réfléchir langlade
oui on est fait a tellement fait le tour
des variantes que tu peux ça irait fou
prend à 3 et labo fouet sur trois of way
of mr qu'on met la mi-automne du temple
pattes toy story choco non et en plus il
a envoyé un gros message à radjabov qui
sait qu'il ya quelque chose à qui le
gêne ça aussi le problème de ce langage
corporel c'est que radjabov quand il va
revenir il est certain que s'ils
trouvent les coûts sont des cookies
jeunes intéressés si il sait que c'est
légal et il connaît même le vaurien mais
là quelques fois il ya un piège et là et
leur foi sans borne qu ils tremblent a
pour programme des ouais non non je te
sors était bien qu'il ait fait mais il
l'a pas fait alors qu'on voit ça lire
les ados on en use un arbitre je sais
pas
dawes a été quelqu'un qui comme vous ils
n'ont
jamais dans le tchat
mais qui sait peut-être maintenant elle
est sûre le chiffre maintenant à des
cinq minutes plus tard elle est là-bas
kouadio qui l'attirent faveur il a fait
vous prend à 3 radjabov qui revient et
alireza qui parle pas trop loin ils
allaient prendre un petit peu d'eau par
est de montrer que tonnerre vaut la
pause sa bouteille à terre et il sera
sciée
il a calculé les gens
armés c'est bien qu'il revienne sur sa
chaise
mais c'est vrai que ça se voit qu'il est
qu il est un peu nerveux mais bon il se
remet bien garde quand même de l'espace
corporelles sur la table il s'est pas
complètement recroquevillé sur sa chaise
alors quoi boîte mal au dos pour faire
semblant
j'ai pas s'il va faire semblant mais en
tout cas
ils calculent ils calculent durcir radja
pas fait ce qui serait pas en train de
réfléchir à une petite draw plutôt que
dans les ligues la variante 1 compliqué
non mais c'est qu'elle réfléchisse plus
être expliqué par quoi parquet où il a
vu qu il peut jouer alors collège dawson
mais il a vu quelques jours pas que
cornet vie est donc maintenant une fois
le fou sur a3 sur l'échiquier il s'est
dit alors plutôt que les jeux 5 ou
plutôt à notre cou qui l'a préparé comme
je pars hkd est-ce qu'il a réfléchi
pendant tout ce temps intime or
aujourd hui un sens des autres mais
salutaire c'est un grand travailleur sur
l'échiquier il ya plein de gens qui
aiment bien de se poser pendant que le
dire j'ai réfléchi au mois par exemple -
oui c'est un grand bosseur sur
l'échiquier
vous prend 4 to b 4 ans il adam booth
pour montrer les deux menaces pas
prononcé cette heure il faut prendre 4
mais attention à la menace numéro un
c'est fou b4 ici et carrière g5 l'idée
c'est que sur fouquet quatre cavaliers
m6 échec au roi
si on prend et d'en prendre cet échec et
mat
mais oh bien sûr en tant que spectateur
j'aimerais qu'ils jouent collège de 5
parce que savoir entre le jour très
complexe à être un jeu à trois résultats
voir nos écrits qui odinga merdé nos
trois
grands favoris du tournoi qui est déjà
en train de s'écrouler
non il n'y a pas eu de coups depuis d'un
me 2 pour 1 8 c'est le chat
l'add on fait un petit tour nous de
notre côté
hikaru qui a peut-être merdé lors diem
pas du tout ce qu'il a fait mais bon est
le roi va peut-être se retrouver faible
côté
américano américano nippon
[Musique]
vidéo - avec la mairie pour leucan
nippo américain et du coup
italo-américain pour fabiano pour les
différencier
qui jouera pas les olympiens il n'a pas
été sélectionné écart ou comment ça je
crois qui je crois que j'ai vu l'équipe
et qu'il n'y ait pas
pourquoi parce que les autres ont
résisté ku et les potes de l'équipe je
crois qu'il avait déclaré que s'il était
remplaçant il voudrait pas jouer 5e la
cadence à quelques tours 5e alors donc
fois bien non les bombes so dominguez
oui ils l'ont quand même que c'était
moins fort que dans un presque voir le
classement 1
d'accord d'accord
ils disent il a refusé et moi j'avais
entendu dire s'il n'était pas si j'étais
pas titulaire il refuserait mais ce
qu'il a refusé parce qu'ils ont mis au
numéro 5 ou est ce qu'il a refusé même
au numéro 4
may à champlan du coup à sa place
ça c'était tout à
ceux dominguez dans la même équipe mais
restait sur ali reza fou prend à 3 jouer
on sait bien que qui lui envoient pas un
coup de mitraillette radjabov là sur le
fou prend à 3 mais d'ailleurs tu va
permettre à ali reza de reprendre ses
esprits il m'a beaucoup réjouie que il
va pas jouer parce que comme ça
peut-être les américains vont pas gagner
une autre fois ci car on joue pas oui
parce que quand même c'est un très très
grand joueur de l'équipe
puisque content parce que vous savoir
peu importe comment vous êtes pour un
général il ya de très bons joueurs de
l'équipe et il y en a pas des joueurs
les joueurs qui sont forts en
en équipe par exemple qui sont notés les
plus grands joueurs de tout le temps le
plus grand jeu aux équipes de tout le
temps sur ma galerie
moi aussi riche et est donc aujourd'hui
je peux vous assurer
qu'ils d'autres ayong riccio que c'est
pas terrible terrible non non c'est pas
terrible
qui d'autre il doit y avoir quelqu'un
d'autre sarkissian à huy où il
s'agissait bien sûr c'est le top 3 dans
tout le temps je pense par rapport à
leur niveau
j'imagine
qu'il a le plus souvent joué les
compétitions par équipes elle a joué le
niveau de 2008 150 kw à la guise qui a
toute sa vie ça a été un joueur de
2007 p ô ô 2006 beaucoup et comment tu
expliques qui joue aussi bien en équipe
bâle est vrai que le drapeau de son pays
et la criée quoi l'afld est
très facile à dire
je suis étonné crade jamin fut aussi
prennent du temps là on sent quand même
que c'est une partie de chauffe un pur
pour tout le monde
oui les 2 sont bien quand même stressé
il faut dire les deux se sent pas trop
dans leur assiette au web dans leur
élément maintenant c'est sûr l'homme le
dilemme dont
de radja
bien sûr et les calculs écologistes il
sait que ce à moins d'aller position
très intéressante où il peut attaquer et
tous - il aura un plan de morue et donc
il sait pas est ce que il va où il voit
pour une option plus haut
[Musique]
alors qu'on nous dit que dean viande
vient de couler est ce que c'est vrai ou
pas
c'est toujours la même on pose c'est
toujours la même pose c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi ce chat ça va être des
banh des fins qui vont tomber petit à
petit qu'ils vont faire du bien pour un
peu nettoyer tout ça
je pense que ça va sévir côté modération
histoire qu'on soit un peu tranquille et
qu'on arrête d'avoir des agitateurs
ouais des agitateurs qui viennent qui
viennent gêner
après c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas grand
chose à se mettre sous la dent la balade
depuis deux petites armes et et au web
donc ils te trois tours but 8 alors à la
dacquoise
lorsqu'à plein de trucs
avocats travaillent et youtube
simple et efficace non
ah oui jeudi les conneries excuses au
nom mais t'inquiète michel on en dit
beaucoup jonglé de trucs parfois
donc la fois x 3 x 3 qui a été jouée on
s'attendait à un coup rapide côté azéri
c'est ce que ça peut permettre à ali
reza de reprendre un peu ses esprits la
ce ce temps mort pour lui vous ne voulez
bien sur ses encouragements bien sûr
c'est très encourageant
parce que ça veut dire que ton que ton
adversaire va les régler ça y est ce
sera une grosse partie
de ses impôts par contre là et doit
faire comme pau
j'espère
et timour qui se lève en confiance
il a l'air en confiance
on va voir c'est son seul cook avait
déjé 6 en réalité
j'espère qu'il va pas faire h 6 allez on
réfléchit le chat
comment les blancs jouent après h 6
est-ce que ça va trouver tu penses aux
est au dessus
ça réfléchit quand même un petit peu
ça réfléchit quand même un petit peu ça
fait plaisir
ça trouve mais bon parce que ç'a aussi
été dit plusieurs fois avant un blad
sinon ça n'aurait pas trouvé ma tondeuse
non ça a été aussi au moins trois fois
mais quand même pas mal votre réaction à
céret p
alors si on joue comme olive jeu 5 ce
que sur kol g6 un vieux jouets h cup
c'est sûr pour h5 et ap est-ce que là on
a le temps de faire tourbe et 8 pour h
cinq cavaliers fuite mais on y arrive si
c'est tu veux dire que c'est trop bon je
suppose
avec plus de pied sur l'échiquier libre
en faut en faire les mêmes choses ou là
qu'est ce que c'est joli voilà donc
illogique ici jouer quand les jeux 6
maintenant h4 va arriver très rapidement
pour eux
pour info radjabov achiary n autorise
décline aussi
je pouvais bien sûr moto de magnac ses
tours 2-3 avec les défauts boukhater
tour h
3o là et là je suppose
j'ai la réponse avec la turbine est
carrière ici on prend qui avaient des
princes cet award
est plutôt étonné que perpétue comme par
exemple le feu qualifié son
collègue ça parce que sur hcc adams a
donc pu rhdp est assez joli d'heure
il sans pierre côté ding ding qui va
finalement et peut-être pas prêt pour le
très haut niveau
ça c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut
tellement donné de confiance à l'epo
malheureusement gagner dès la première
ronde avec les noirs
dans le meilleurs
des meilleurs scénarios dans la partie
ii dim que tu as donc et devient
complètement raide mais il sort de la
partie
et une vi qui a une double gaffe côté
ding va voir ce qui s'est passé quand
même avant de revenir
roy
h21 et diane les des jeux 5 tours chant
gh3 gh3 et donc je points pour l'instant
elle est pas un air donc un pays où se
permettre un truc en bresse ain
conditionnant voir que les survivants
bah je pense que c'est pas si mauvais
quoi au moins tu vois paraître mois de
quoi
aller laisser on va les laisser jouer
engrangé que 6 mois
au kenya fougeux 4,6 mais bon on va
rester sur
sur timour qui hésitent
ou et donc il hésite en alors peut-être
ils vont annuler il veut alors elle donc
ils résident
faire cette nuit là sur l'échiquier ou
alors h4 réel et aux eaux-vives quoi
ça c'est dit au pif 3 hardy frais
ils jouent ils envoient h4 on l'a vu un
d'une main certaines
n'en voyez donc ça va partir parce que
c'est typique pour a déjà
joué comme ça qu il est content pour
faire nous les moyens tout d'un coup et
tout d'un coup qu'est ce que c'est
typique typique non j'avais dit les
méthodes jodo cas quoi
ouais alors qu'ali raisons aient pu
jouer qu'un valet détroit et prendre là
nul assez facilement avec les noirs il
laissait alireza jouer et tout d'un coup
il change de de braquet ballet raison
d'eux mais c'est très malin c'est très
fort ce qu'il en train de faire un petit
mot à sa pas l'air d'être le même si
moore celui qu'on a vu en norvège c'est
pas le même niveau
passible de possible que le moins bon
voire plus tard
[Musique]
t'aimes pas trop oui je n'aime pas trop
aimé h4 dangereux et donc si on h 6 ans
10 ans ont fait h5 et on enlève le
cavalier lecavalier obligé de partir
c'est toujours la même chose à ces
cavaliers m6 puis on prend et d'un match
7 mat non mais vous aviez dit a donc dit
prêt alors donc bouffer sur trois est
lorraine que c'est le matos et regardez
ce qu'est ce que ça donne d'ailleurs
maintenant sipa da dam de dôme et
cavaliers de 2006 ont montré que non non
non et avons aussi que les deux
aient h6
pas sur le compteur est votre dame d'oé
tout six mois ci c'est le coup de blues
mécanique on
est ce que fout prend un cavalier mais
le problème c'est que tu t'en
débarrasser mais tu perds tu as plus
forte pièces donc maintenant tu restes
avec une qualité de moins et la position
est juste mauvaise pour les noirs le
problème c'est qu'avec les noirs on peut
pas se permettre de liquider parce que
si on liquide toutes les pièces et qu'on
reste avec une tour contre un fou balle
et blanc il vous gagner facilement
face permettre ça on n'a pas le choix là
que de garder l'activité
ali reza qui réfléchit de nouveau et
côté car ou est ce que ça ça s'arrange
ouais ce qu'yves ce que veut dire
fabiano c'est que s'ils bloquent les
pions sur des 5,4 et g4 le foot cases
blanches m marche 1 ok mais les
arrivants des 4 c'est terminé un clou et
qu'il va essayer à leurs d'offrir sa
symphony sur les cases noires et tu fais
b4 qui a valu b3 qui avaient des 4 c'est
terminé je pense oui
quoique peut-être c'est pas les seuls
cas où tu veux le rémunère
je sais pas peut-être je suis en train
de dire une connerie il met peut-être
support d'un bout à l'autre dirais que
même
comment dire comme si dirai tout
beaucoup les enfants connaissent trop
peut-être russie -
et d'ailleurs pour les débutants je veux
mentionner aussi que si on change tous
les tours
et
on garde la dame cavaliers contre l'aide
d'un maillot fouet le roi au noir est
faible et souvent se considérer comme un
problème parce que conquois les
combinaisons foot dames et cavaliers
compteur dame faut un blues coup droit
adverse faible d'américains alliés sont
beaucoup trop fort normalement ou et ça
c'est logique parce que la dame et le
cavalier font deux choses différentes
alors que la dame est il fou pour les
mêmes choses vont et souvent c'est bien
d'avoir une pièce fait quelque chose de
supplémentaire c'est pour ça que la tour
il fauche ou bien ensemble d'ailleurs
aussi ouais
tu te rappelles qui viennent que mille
fois je te dis tu te rappelles qui offre
un général
et chaos
n'est pas vraiment au courant de
domination des mauvais de bons fous tu
l'attends a souvent parlé ouais ouais
qui sous-estimé cette notion là haut et
comme aujourd'hui
maintenant ça alireza un kir tank du
temps or c'est une position qu'il a
forcément eu en tête
ont déjà assez longtemps
c'est je suis pas je suis pas bien
je ne suis pas bien
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas rassurant
ce qu'on est en train de voir
charteau charte et le devra qu'à moins
offrir quelques stages dans les villes
d'eaux calmes quoi
je pense nous propose h5 dans le chat
est sûre h5 je pensais même bien dame
prend un chemin qui on va rentrer de ce
côté au
pénible
est-ce que tu mourras bluffant début de
partie n'ont pas vraiment mais sait on a
son style et son style et c'est le
danger c'est comme ça qu'ils espèrent
gagner le tournant faisant rien en
forçant l'adversaire à prendre des
risques et l'adversaire qui se dit bon
bah de façon ils jouent pour nulle j'en
prends pas trop et finalement on a tout
d'un coup ils se réveillent tel un lion
ce saint mathieu affamés et un os aire
juin comme ça que se sent confortable
complètement
cendre us s'appellent de jouer avec de
nombreux lots
à temps mauvaise nouvelle il ya
peut-être au sk temps est-ce que ça est
ce que est ce qu ont encore live
il ya quelque chose qui dit que ça
accroche avec toutes les caméras mais si
on est encore là il veut juste pas
cliquer
et on va rester live
écoute
ça dit que je prie mais ça marche encore
donc ça va ça passe
ça fasse comme ça tu sais tu sais moi
j'ai pas d'expérience était hyper rigide
pour moi
qui relance un tu vas y à rien de
rien d'incroyable 1
pourquoi pas que relay h 4 parce que
comment les six j'ai évidemment cette
mode
est ce qu'on a encore les caméras c'est
la question que je me pose maintenant si
ça avance encore
est ce que dame sait si c'est suicidaire
bah oui prime c'est qu'on a une qualité
de monde donc on peut pas se permettre
d'échanger les dames pour rien en fait
ouais faut jouer dynamique ssii comme
atos re
équipe en h4 ça passe bien je vous
laisse répondre à la question dans le
chatt al et ceux qui ont déjà répondu
vous répondez pas ceux qui connaissent
la réponse instantanément pour les
autres on réfléchit
et ça que c'est une mauvaise d'air et
oui parce que c'est hyper il faut que
les sa nature et kireev six échecs les
noirs doivent prendre bouger le roi et
un match cet échec et mat
et f5 c'est bizarre que beaucoup
d'absents que c'est toujours la même
chose en fait
c'est toujours le même problème de
partout en fait
sauf que là c'est pas marqué mais bon
c'est pas mal tout de suite mais ça va
l'être
une époque qui joue enfin g5 ok mais
c'est pas si clair clair un nom oui il
faut pas trop croire les ordinateurs
landing ça peut encore tenir
encore tenir
salut cave de mon point de vue de
débutant je n'arrive pas à discerner qui
est mieux dans cette position pire son
c'est le dojo bio
mais peut-être plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs c'est plus les blancs qui ont
une chance de mettre la pression sur
leurs adversaires
donc les blancs sont un
peu mieux en pratique
donc oui il m'a écouté on a que attendra
maintenant
pas grand chose d'autre à faire
on a vraiment fait le tour de la
position et des options de des joueurs
maintenant il faut que la partie se
déroule
pourquoi pas qui avec quatre essais la
même chose encore c'est pas possible
mais le fait exprès il a gagné le tour
de vis est risqué où il joue bien en
fait
ils troll
est ce qu'il existe ici la glace eskimos
oui bien sûr
hausse
être papa vraiment poster son
réseau problèmes matériels en fait si on
reprend pas le matériel on va finir par
échanger des 4 contre ces 7es à 7 est
resté avec une qualité de loin sur les
droits et perdre la partie en fait donc
en gros on est plus ou moins obligés
d'aller la chercher cette qualité
c'est comme une balance en fait le
problème c'est que la balance matériel
est trop derrière et si les autres
balance ségalis ben ça va rester moins
bien
pascal sacrifiant un pion en rendant en
pinot noir
tu es mort a réussi de s'activer grave
ouais et donc maintenant pas qu'on va
voir maintenant ce sont les points qui
sont plus est donc maintenant c'est à
tour
c'est le tour de noir de comédiens deux
dômes de bouffer du matos
est vraiment pas bien fait ton rêve 6 3
juin est revenue et j'ai cinq
au québec 5 /
/ / / parce qu'il faut faire quelque
chose jaj
pressé j'ai objets sur hbo s'est
focalisée 6 donc d'un bo5
et la
dame deux ans et le voir il faut voir
dans l'es5 parce que sûr que le 3e tour
ok un but le voir - il faut le voir
comme ça je pense que les pauvres à la
gagne très franchement je
traiterai de seconde
écoutez j'espère quand même qu'ils ont
au moins
elle est réservé aux panneaux de se voir
comme saragosse
serait bien trop
et ici j'ai l'impression que tout a joué
complètement freiner quoi
ah ouais juste je pense qu'il a tout
fait ce qu'ils devaient pas faire parce
que maintenant je pense que les noirs
sont vraiment pas loin d'égaliser ok si
on obtient lui obtient un tel pause
après le but pour savoir mam après avoir
c'est ce que la yuuwaa
dramatique quoi mais pour le moment ça
donne l'impression qu'ils leur victoire
de nespouls victoire de caruana aussi
peut-être pas pour l'instant si vous
voulez le sentiment qu'il ya deux
terriers à domec chaud et les autres ne
sont pas tout à fait les encore je parle
donc dopé théâtre corona est peut-être
là n'y aurait ni pour les deux qui ont
déjà d'ailleurs gagné
des canadiens oui qui savent comment ça
de ce master alors oui voilà et les
autres sont conquois un peu frileux ou
quoi
wamiz bands
bon allez reza qui fait quand même de
plus en plus peur la
fiero aucun mental je sais pas si c'est
aux commentaires ouais il est vrai au
toucher qui sont importantes
dans les prix bas comment il faut alors
choisir le balance entre les
préparations techniques et les pros
pression psychologique parce que il est
vrai vous pourrez être archi bien
préparés au niveau des ouvertures par
exemple est moins physiquement mais ici
les psychologies n'est pas à la hauteur
tout est un vin
donc il faut jamais oublier ce facteur
l'est si vous n'êtes pas
mais comment s'appelle natural born
killers
donc est par contre c'est le demande le
domaine l'oubli ou négligés par les
joueurs
je sais de quoi je parle de loin le plus
négligé même ceux qui ont visité une
seule fois un bon psy sont prêts
ils sont très peu quoi
pourtant la plupart des joueurs de l'est
de naples c'est l'émoi bisons par contre
ceux qui ont été menées le match robben
killers conca profond castro ont très
souvent visités donc ceux qui auraient
en fait même à surprendre à chaque fois
comme
par exemple je sais qu'il n'est pas
prescrit en fait danser rigueur avant
son match contre
pourtant déjà nouveau absolument besoin
c'est étonnant et
ouais je pense que peut-être les joueurs
de chair parmi les joueurs du haut
niveau c'est peut-être ce qui fonde le
manga face à man notre époque où l'on
pense que non non non c'est pas pour moi
si je suis arrivée là donc déjà je suis
très fort mentalement non non pas du
tout tu vois les gens ce qu'ils se
cassent
les le système nervis qu'au bout de
quelques années
comme sajoo avis quoi ce que tu veux que
j'aille le chercher un petit peu d'eau
avant les designers les chocs les
chattes et de l'eau chercher des chattes
et de l'eau j'arrive là
voilà donc sinon nos amis et l'otan un
autre jeu avait presque égale déjà parce
que firoud et à 28,15 contre 27 49 orad
gens réfléchis toujours nous les shoots
en fait les choses avec comme gengembre
un truc comme
du même type pour l'énergie pas les
choses dont vous aviez pensé bien sûr
donc si vous voulez c'est malgré tout
l'expérience qui viennent à moi aussi
quand même c'est assez choquant ce qu'on
voit au matin dans cette partie parce
que donc tout tracé ainsi dit tout à
l'heure il ya une heure qui il réfléchit
postulat elle veut faire les
mitraillettes mais là est ce qu'il est
en train de faire c'est la pire des
décisions parce que il réfléchit
traîneront il faut quand même les coups
qu'ils recouvraient au budo quelques
secondes et c'est la pire d'approcher le
spot y'est c'est très étonnant parce que
ça fait il est à une heure et demie de
réflexion sur la variante name donné
trois coups mail ouais donc à la vôtre
et de différends et à la sauvetage d
offrir aux dans cette partie quand même
qui est devenu un peu trop bizarre je
cherchais le ravito
donc en a marre gengembre pour que moi
je prends à prendre celui-là
à la partie tellement étonnante dinghy
rennes a gaffé encore
il pas moi c'est un peu trop quand même
et c'est quand même un peu trop vlad
j'avançais pas pour l'érection plus tôt
oui bien sûr y compris pour l'érection
montagne
tel ardiden -4 déjà ouais ça va être
plutôt pour les pauvres alors oui sur la
cls est complètement couvert de la cie
punto
olala encore une autre fois le chinois
dit soin de soi au début du tournoi et
conduit les fragiles c'est horrible
comble nouvelle pour moi perso mais
après j'étais étonné qu'il arrive à
madrid que mercredi ou jeudi
mais que sait jamais je n'ai jamais vécu
ce choix peut être pas les parties bulls
a interdit un truc oui je sais mais
j'arrive arrivant avec un jet lag de fou
probablement plus de 24 heures de vol
notre travail au savon et il tourne même
s'il priait et il va perdre c'est trop
tôt de dire mais pour l'instant bien sûr
nostra dieu c'est un sur quoi comme ou
d'une autre à mme lanusse
en fait on a bu nostra planus
et ça a l'air d'être hyper fort c4
au moins d'impôts nouveaux lits jeu au
moins une bonne nouvelle
parce que comme je vous ai dit pendant
nostra la deuce pas encore nostra à new
soul pas quoi
j'ai rien contre si on voit bien au
grain ou si rien
ne sera nulle ce n'est pas courant
[Rires]
en fait c'est lui le str à la
whey comment dire dans quel choc auprès
de la cara gamme logan utah
antiquités avec
magnifique non
on dirait deux bouts footbag écoute on
essaye de s'occuper comme on peut hein
tiens moi j'ai pas compris ce matin
à les résas regarder mtv et vieillot
le comment dire les vidéos d'on afro
s'étonnant c'est très étonnant ce qui
est en train de se passer qu'est ce que
ce fort aux lettres à thiant petit russe
à peu près se posent
le jeu les quoi
compliqué compliqué compliqué on sait
pas trop quoi vous dire l'acea mais ça
c'est vrai que sur cette variante qui
paraissait évidente on est sur cette
position depuis depuis une heure et
demie et ali raison c'est pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il va faire une
grosse connerie tout d'un coup et perdre
deux trois coups après
non pas tant que ça quand même parce que
ici 47 pur calcul je comprends que c'est
plus routes et sèment un serveur tout
oui ici ceux des purs calculs s'il se
faire quelque chose à merveille c'est
bien ça il aime pas mais il voit
trouverez oui il est vrai que le tableau
final ils n'ont pas
des tests même
en fait il fallait juste prendre là nul
et pas à s'inventer une vie
c'est la question que vous qu'on se pose
et nous en début de semaine et ce qu'il
fallait tout tenté contre radjabov
première partie déjà vous faire une
nulle tranquille et il n'a pas fait
soviétique jusqu'au bout non moins
disons que tu peux tout tenter
quand tu vois que les mecs blancs bien
ok c'est
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs après tout c'est
toi qui aimais le noir mais bien sûr
d'abord je pars
chercher la bagarre et mothma
chercher la sortie
ouest l'impression bizarre
tu veu t pas carrés voisine
eh bien je serai sûrement contenter de
la nuit je pense à une belle
professionnels way elles veulent y
seraient déjà dans sa chambre d'hôtel
lui afin de se reposer prépare et écrire
50 messages j'ai bossé dur de trouver
roubaud 4
est ce que c'est moi faut beau cadeau
c'est poids des autres
je pense qu'ils troll mais tu as quelque
chose qui lui plaît pas regarde il est
il est anxieux mais là il faut qu'ils
jouent opus il reste seize coups à jouer
il n'y a pas trente secondes on vient
quand quand il m'a traité 5 minutes
tiens ok il sait dire tout à l'heure je
suis tombé victime
de son approche judokas oui
et maintenant je veux faire
ce taux calculé je vois que c'est égal
mais je vais faire sans boire
je trempais faire le ippon à la fin
ouais
donc en gros ce sont deux points qui
remonte qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui quoi
et on nous dit et comment ça qu'ils
m'ont toutefois il n'ya pas
d'encadrement parce que ça fait
peut-être 80 g plus combien d'années que
j'ai dit aux mecs de la fidh que le
dégoût grave avec cette cadence au
candidat quoi
elle va permettre d'ancrer mans c'est
bizarre et un personnel a contredit
d'ailleurs ils m'ont tous dit ah oui ah
bon il faut réfléchir jeudi me suis
hyper content de faire cette compétition
avec cette cadence à la cour fin mai ce
qui est bizarre c'est que ils font chier
le monde à faire des parties longues
tout au long de l'année pour pâques et
rhodia et nate ewell pas autant et pour
les candidats en fait ils renient marque
moi j'aime bien qu'ils aient pas d'un
crémant juste pour moi en fait il ya
deux ok il ya une heure 52 30 je
m'inquiète pas pour moi ces choses que
ce poste choses tendent vers le joueur
je suis en philosophiquement c'est
bizarre ces choses comme toutes les
veilles et jours une cadence est ici
d'un coup tout à fait quatre médailles
or c'est quelque chose dont j'avais
parlé mais c'est étrange que les
cadences entre les qualifications les
candidats elle matches championnat du
monde soit pas les mêmes oui bien sûr
non il faut une unification des
canadiens
en enlevant peut-être cinq heures et
demie
après c'est quoi la suite s'il vous
plaît on les dit mme aubé 4 h 5 fu des
deux dames de deux ou quatre
noms d'abord peut-être
attendre
foucque
si ça marche comme ça c'était fou et 4
cavalli ou quatre cavaliers h4h 6 affi
si c'était ça la ligne est là un coup
jean retour des 8
oui hg fou prend des deux quelque chose
comme ça
en d2 il donne déjà gagnant lors d'un
coup droit je sauterai jet airways pour
empêcher un cavalier six dames h7 est
sûr qu'il va y avait six maintenant il
ya des projets de maths écoutez duo
conquois du raf être pas vraiment à
votre trottoir d opposition qui lui
plaît pas mais on sait ça qu'ils
n'aiment pas
moi son cavalier son droit n'est pas sur
le terre n'en voulait pas sur le terrain
écouter mozart tout le monde sait que
les hommes elles le cojones est un très
bon défenseur du roi du roi le milliard
d'eur et donc
ok bien sûr c'est en quelque sorte
désagréable mais
tu as cherché la tempête
il a joué en fourbe et 4 je me répète ça
vient d'être jouée fou bekkat on va voir
un peu s'ils ont réussi à cerner une
émotion sur le visage de radjabov
ils ont l'air fatigué nom ou c'est une
impression elle donne toujours cette
impression là
grave qui tombe la veste
raja va fonds affirme déjà pardon a dit
reza qui tombe la veste et qui se firent
le jazz tomber la veste de cuir ou jack
c'était quoi les chansons en français la
chemise tomber la chemise le
code java qui doit sentir qu'il a une
chance aujourd'hui peut-être
c'est donc il adopte une rolex sur sa
main gauche
et maintenant l'air hors
prêts ou de terminèrent déterminé il vos
photos sur beyond sur la case alpha 0e
mairie les préoccupent et russie non au
oui mais là pour la première fois de ma
vie je vois qu'ils croient ils semblent
ils sont les proies quoi quand elle
sanglote recensant les proies quoi là
elle est un mode de chasseurs je sais
très bien qu est ce que veut dire cette
position cette gestuelle corporelle il a
envie de se taper un petit j'allais à la
chasse aux
prix le
[Rires]
goût
excellent
vrai mais il est jeune il a dit rajaona
aux cougars
[Musique]
et regarder fuir ou d'ailleurs oui il
est en outre le poids la taille et la
note 3 la
voisine caisse moi
mais ça va il va résister ne t'inquiète
pas
ok digne c'est terminé coca
ding se termine à dos et caroulle ça
devrait pas durer très longtemps ah non
non non dans telle pose des beats you
deux îles et les imprécisions de
chirurgicaux et non non carmona ferrone
parce que il faut calculer parce que le
roi est faible parce que pas d'âge est
très souvent les chirurgiens
donc duda a tout raté non pas tout raté
mais d'apparence beaucoup raté quoi
ce que je leur ai recommandé de jouer au
poker
qu'à
abobo pas et puis et le noir de vaud
doivent être précis comment va la fin
mais bon il a raté beaucoup parce que
sinon voilà que s'il continue de la même
manière quoi
un truc qui m'a mis c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'on rigole comme des hyènes ya
micha qui vient nous voir
disait le moc hogarth a rappelé pays
heureux et j'ai dit est ce que michel
reconnaît pas les syriens mais je
reconnais ce rire quoi
d'ailleurs ce soir il faut que je coûte
le centre et des hyènes pour essayer de
limiter demain
elle ricane en fait on
rigole
mais ça chico téti mort il envoie pas h5
tempo la partie est très étrange livre
réellement les possesseurs sais ce que
c'est ça ce que mme warren d'une autre à
radio j m parce que les partis rhdp le
deuxième 6 14 parties de fuir ou 2d
comme ça 14 points c'est ryan qua non
mais c'est étrange l'ailé les temps de
réflexion sont pas naturels du tout
est-ce que vous avez la main par l'inde
russe a bien sûr vous avez là ma part
qu'une rue sainte est
la première ronde exactement esquimaux
et c'est peut-être une ronde difficile
pour les deux joueurs
psychologiquement
on voit digne se faire défoncer ouais
c'est pas propre
[Musique]
à sas est pas très hygiénique wii
ou la plus aux
puits sont onze à cause d'un tir que je
lis en fait
à cause de alger tôt reprend 1,8 échec
est roi chez 7 avec l'été rouages 2 et
sûrement tout revenu hebdo d'un mois je
te
je lis certes mais plus facile qui vous
fait vous la moindre le reprocher quoi
vraiment facile ça
non pas du
commerce et dingle jolie saint roch et
non mais c'est beau
d'ailleurs corelio aussi savoir
mon colis
rêve dauda moi j'adore voir comment les
trois je préfère comme ça donc en 3e
rang s'il te plaît et koné soit
ok
oui c'était padding irène c'était dingli
jeunes aujourd'hui
voilà ouais si c'est dû cliché il a fait
four
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est comme le à trois noms et là était
la vraie fourrure
[Rires]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
mais c'est quoi ce coup leur chef wave 2
je pense
dit quoi
enfin
non c'est pas si mauvais
et radjabov qui réfléchit après fou b4
c'est incroyable parce que ça fait une
heure et demie qui peut réfléchir à 7 à
cette position sur le temps d'aller reza
et côté gérer il sait pas une partie
d'échecs
c'est comme j'ai pas un groupe les
vignes on voit
et donc mais dites moi alors on commence
par vous
mettiez d'ailleurs c'est quoi le
problème entre vous
bon et maintenant vous vous en pensez
quoi
alors que le bus le problème est là mais
on sait pas comment comment expliquer
maintenant alors que le psy lui comme
nous il sait très bien c'est juste que
5n plus
[Rires]
qu'elle est si large quoi ouais parce
que c'est sa cinquième pas tous au fond
dans le couple
ouais ouais y'a pas de mots pour le dire
ou non
[Rires]
sa gueule partout - dell est sur toi la
gare
sorte
[Rires]
olala
ça qui
a perdu un oeil yann presque je suis
mexique et en quoi
c'est terrible oh non mais c'est juste
un club et
le h en cours de marche je connais pas
bien le h
je crois qu'on a conclu la partie est
trop dur a commenté en fait
oripeaux geos rien il faut fouiller
t'aidera crucial et
what we
came à ne pas vraiment les spécialistes
elle les dodos mono et
wayne on s'est compliqué mais c'est ça
qu'on a commencé à être sur cette
position il était genre 16 heures hélas
les 18h27 en fait ça fait vraiment 2h27
deux heures quoi un peu moins et
peut-être
16h30 vraiment arriver ce fait deux
heures qu'on a vu cette position sur
l'écran rajaa a livré son commence à
peine sa veste costard que son costa
normalement ça ça veut dire
oui ça veut dire que le moment est
important ouais enfin c'est pas normand
a toujours quoi on n'enlève pas le
costard pour d'autres raisons d'habitude
étrange comme partie mais là de façon ça
a forcément accéléré puisque ils vont
être ils vont être obligés de jouer
maintenant à 16,8 contre 20 il reste
quinze coups il n'y a pas trente
secondes il va tu t'es obligé d'envoyer
deux trois coups là
elle est
renvoyée par le parti gym pour et de
reconception
quarantine est en cours pendant trois
ans le pauvre
c'est le money time
alors de 2 bravo lord yens pas au poids
ou de douleur et a parlé de 2 à acheter
se serait séparé cité d'amd de le
problème on avait regardé h6 alger sa
cette absence être un problème à ggf
comprend qu'un valet projet 5
mais ça c'est censé être un problème
mottaki magis perdre a dit rezaï
qui va tu voyais les propositions
d'ordinateurs ces dames de 2
h 6 alger à ggf
roi f7 avec l'idée que les jeux cinq
doivent eux oui plutôt aller sur ce plan
ce qui peut trouver ouais ça peut être
dans son style sa wii lui et ça ça peut
encore s'y trouve ça ça peut encore
tenir loin il va pas être ma lancée
c'est le 17 mai
après 1,5 à 4 m et en voir rétivité à
tout prix quoi si l'aca il a une chance
par contre si la tour prends ce que je
voyais avec la dame qui arrive en c2
ouais enfin il y en a qu un peuple il en
est capable
donc si vous voulez aller à transférer
son papy vers 2,7 pour garantir que les
finales sont pour rien
parce que le roi sur de cette fois être
très proche du pion à passer pour ceux
qui n'ont pas compris d'abord
at façon ça va forcément là les coûts
ont forcément s'enchaîner ya plus de
son pied du mur
est ce que tu penses que rajab affalé
nerfs encore pour bien jouer un de saïx
note comme ça oh il est aussi fort qu'il
lui était pas passible quoi voici les
bons c'est une interrogation web bien
sûr parce que
parfois je me dis que quelque chose qu
il n est plus capable d'avouer six mois
pour la première fois elle a gagné terre
d'autres choses des noms et puis il
gagne ainsi ce truc là où les foyers
pour jeunes cmj il s'est qualifié deux
fois pour sinon
je vois non il est toujours capable
parfois quand elle veut vraiment donc
plutôt derajah et parce que rajab
est très chic ce besoin les jeunes
générations puissent être des bombes les
deux soeurs n'ont globalement excellent
les azéri globalement ol azéri de blitz
est excellente en bien sûr
d'ailleurs l'école arménienne aussi
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir foule
prend 4 on nous propose dans le chat qui
va les prendre 4 et cavaliers ou sept
alors ça le danger c'est de se retrouver
avec des cases noires
qui crient famine de tels d'eutelsat
tape dans l'écran plupart des cas ce
mode si beau adams un coût de 35 coups
mais ça se termine soit parce que c'est
moi qui ont comme les dans son échiquier
moins de délits final c'est moi et le
roi et même s'il fait une finale de
cavaliers ça peut être c'est moi sur le
8e ou c'est moi peu sur access avec la
tour où il ya pas mal des variations
domois t il va probablement jouer h61 de
toute façon il faut qu'ils aient leur
wife 7 mai ça m'inquiète parce qu'il
continue à réfléchir je jeu parce qu'il
a bien vu quand il faut prendre des deux
dames prend des de tain
je sais mystérieux pour moi
est ce qu il faut chaud au chat
non mais bon peut-être il a perdu le
climat leur insue de à la chaleur ça
rien mais c'est quand même étonnant
enfin il vient de faire vous prendrez de
dame prend des deux y vient de réfléchir
il vient de réfléchir à temps je vais je
vais lire ses écrits 23 minutes pour
fouler 4 puis quatre minutes pour fou
prend des deux il avait déjà pris 37
minutes pour vous prend à 3 enfin cette
position là c'était quand même la main
il ça fait une
le pire tueur
winter à part d'acteurs parcourir dans
les finales
c'est vrai on n'a pas vraiment beaucoup
plus défendre oui parce que la table il
attaque toujours sait pas se défendre et
radjabov l'a compris
ça le pire scénario au fait qu'il n'ya
pas que les finales
ne pas savoir comment défendre c'est
possible oui c'est possible
je sais dolist indienne avec les noirs
ce qu'il a fait par de sa vie tu te
défends pas souvent parce que
tu as perdu en plein autant de l'espace
que tu te défends pas confondre oui
plutôt de laisser passer des points
d'eau
indique dean wir eine abandonné mais ça
c'était déjà
clair et net ouais ça abandonné côté
ding on peut on peut jeter un oeil
mais pau qui commence sur les chapeaux
de roue en victoire avec les noirs
facile
quelle déception
sa grimace un côté n'est pas ça
s'arrange le thermos ah non moi c'est
sûr que mes pots avec la camorra c'est
l'oubli au grand crohot pas visuellement
ouais ouais
et ça joue encore à la fois les plus
graves acrobates faciale
mais ça a joué un côté un quota l'iresa
il a joué h6
bon faut qu'ils aient droit province est
en fait si la roma prend un f5 ça va
encore
après c'est peut-être la peur de perdre
la première partie du tournoi aussi un
qui s'y met les joueurs dans cet état ça
fait quand même très longtemps qui se
prépare il faut se dérouiller
trop de responsabilités sur ses jeunes
épaules
rajab hommes jouent pas tous les
meilleurs coups maintenant
y réfléchit aussi à il joue vraiment pas
un coup tempo à aucun des deux
trop de près
cette pratique
trop d'excitation
le sentiment de trop de responsabilités
surtout de responsabilité
de voir un bout les spectateurs après il
faut dire qu ali reza avait déclaré
qu'il était là pour apprendre et que et
qui comptait pas forcément jouer la
victoire dans ses premiers candidats
mais on voit au vu de cette racaille qui
met ses ratios maître coq 1 1 les
françaises tu vois ok je veux pas je
veux pas bah écoute bien sûr tu veux
quoi
il faut jamais croire et je veux pas le
seul qui a vraiment déclaré qu'il y
allait pour gagner c'est duda
sauf qu'il faut jamais gagné
ok pour l'instant en donc dire que pire
du mauvais ma camarade pierre nickel
donc
dota
rapporte plutôt news ça va
qu'est ce que tout le monde s'en fout on
est maintenant alors donc ici il faut
pas faut pas sombrer ouais mais bon on
peut encore la gagner un sait on
on est on est inquiet mais en fait si la
le roi prend f7 même si la turbine est
plutôt les blancs fut loin d'être sûr
que dans un temps point de vue pratique
son avantage c'est juste très chaud
surtout avec aussi peu de temps non je
comprends ce qui peut te faire un
problème - tuer les mois qui viennent
c'est que par exemple la
ggf roef sept collèges 5 heures ou hspa
ou
8% je vais dire qu'après 3 qui aurait
ainsi signifié la manière d'un zoo
d'alger s'il faut trouver quelque chose
de rapide au second
tour ah oui au fait pas du tout récent
en fait j'avais pas vu la tour n'est pas
bien brasser sauf que les bien placé
pour défendre le roi way sinon on n'est
pas bien
et après tu pars de l'autre côté un nom
je comprends moi qui tourne ok je
comprends que c'est pas que tard la fête
non plus loin c'est l'espoir c'est un
souffle d'espoir si l'aca il n'est pas
perdant
souffrante mais ça peut même tourner et
qui sait ça joue quoi
caruana
d'affaires être pénible pour icare où je
pense pour icare ou le tournoi peut être
très long ci commence à perdre voilà
voilà qu'il recommence dos trimé pendant
le tournoi un échelon psychologiquement
ça va être dur quand tu viens tu t'es
qualifiée un peu comme ça la rage tu
viens au tournoi t'as pas envie d'être
ridicule évidemment et si tu commences
avec déjà une défaite étant par une
deuxième ça peut être vraiment
pas que ça
caruana n'a qu'à un patronat
particulièrement away j'avais pas
particulièrement il se prononçait mille
fois sur ce sujet il s'est propagé en
gros il a prêté du traître
quand l'autre partie de la liste
conneries à la liste des talibans et
l'est et puis retourner oui il à dire
ouvertement à plusieurs voire à bois tu
peux pas faire ça il n'a pas tant d ela
pas tort d'ailleurs et donc c'est aussi
personnelle en tant que les packs lee du
coup city
au ven 22
oui non et ça ça peut ça peut être un
tournoi qui peut être qui peut être
compliqué
par contre il n'ya pas que
wesley bucyquois
et peut-être ça s'arrête pas là puisque
le début de la liste
non mais c'est vrai que tu as beaucoup
de joueurs comme ça qui sont d outsider
comme tout art rapporte radjabov naka où
tu dis si ça a pas si ça se passe bien
ils peuvent devenir dangereux et si ça
se passe mal en réalité
c'est à dire que le vainqueur des
candidats pourraient finir cette année à
plus 4 voire même plus 5 il ya beaucoup
de clients potentiels en fait c'est
juste je sais de moi jamais le tournoi
est hyper bon et par exemple tu
commences moelle dès les premières
parties tout bouffe dû rentrer dans ta
chambre tu as perdu une autre hui tu
peux tu vois les redifs où tu peux
streamé mais c'est trop tentant quand
même d'appuyer sur le bouton click et au
hasard et de recommencer de stream est
quoi parce que bien sûr c'est pire que
l'indépendance sexuelle quoi
clairement surtout qu'à mon avis pendant
des toits comme ça tu as des risques de
cumuler les deux
[Rires]
trop de stress
un en dur mais prends pas pourquoi il
faut en fait je comprends rien cette
partie là c'est vraiment la partie à
laquelle j'ai rien compris j'ai dit les
taux sont sur le sofa dans psycho
et non d'ailleurs le psy cette fois ci
c'est non
ok on peut enfin coup tempo ou là whaou
enfin au combo ya trop heureux
aller exactement comment ya 3
en 1 combien de voix
mais en plus un âne gris plus
1,20 ou 30 pour les bons ici point qu'un
tour avec les tours à boeufs et demi
donc foutyou donc maintenant pour
fight et livio avec le pape y
est les résas please
et on dit que d'houdain et gagnant
on souffle
et plutôt vers 1,8 du coup no way
et donc d'un indice gagnant
encore compliqué quand même moi qui
gagne un bon il faut pédaler en cours
pour gagner ça écoute et dernièrement
malgré tout ce que leur dit il faut y
voi 8 allée les groupes waouh
il accélère ali réserve at il été avant
tout il est peut-être dans son élément
l'a de nouveau
à allez allez allez allez
ça peut ça peut ça peut bien tourné pour
nous vlad hockey en connaissant radja
ex joueurs archi dynamique il va pas
fort et trois ans que nous sommes radja
il va faire j'ai pas un truc tout con
tour simple tort parce que sur dalle ses
diatribes 5 avec un temps pourri donc
c'est plutôt qu'il va faire peut-être
tout ça tranquille je suppose oui il va
jeu dynamique moi ça et en plus quand
même comment il joue plus ou moins
d'éléments de style toute sa vie oui
c'est un bon chasseur
quand il sent les chevreuils
charogne la charogne il est il et il
gère son couteau quoi il est il mate pas
le truc qui recherchent le couteau coin
il est dangereux et ce qu'il faudrait
pas un petit mur d'aller la france
est ce que tu penses qu'un mur peut
aider bah oui allez un petit buzz ont
quelque chose de notre part ou à laisser
je pensais le moment là
que dix minutes 1 quand même pour dix
courts ça peut encore gaf 1 bah oui bien
sûr
quoiqu'il ya pas beaucoup de pièces mais
mais c'est peu de temps si on a ça y est
allé la france qui partent
voile timour st500 regard il est pas
bien là il est pas bien ça s'est vu
il est dans le dur timour
une partie se termine quand même
aujourd'hui relativement vite hein parce
qu'on a déjà caruana gagnant contre
nakamura duda gagnant gagnant - gagnant
gagnant au domaine en dominant
dominant mais quand même après 3h40 de
jeu c'est rare d'avoir toutes les
parties avec un quiz à 5 ans je me
disais assez sanglant ouais sauf que les
victimes sont pas dangereux est vrai
mais ces cinq ans c'est pas moi non non
ça envoie c'est pas un tournoi à les
candidats c'est un tournant il ya des
résultats des pays riches thebaut a dit
d agathe ou say it does the goodbye
ice cube ouais
d'ailleurs excellents comme le pour un
nom de rappeur ice cube
et schott
finish a commencé de pousser le son est
cinglé chez le singe hasharon israël
sans machine
regarde radjabov regard il est pas bien
quand même il sait qu'il est gagnant
mais il sait plus comment gagner ça fait
combien de temps qu'il n'a pas gagné une
partie du jeu d'échecs x radjabov au jeu
d'iran longue ça fait longtemps qu'il
n'a pas juste gagner une partie du
trajet
ça fait autant qu'elle n'a pas perdu de
partir mais qu'ils avaient gagné une
partie du jeu d'échecs
10 radjabov va tomber
possible il lui reste plus que huit
minutes
ah non mais il traîne vraiment trop la
gestion du temps catastrophique
en norvège elle n'a pas gagné une seule
partie classique
quelqu'un dit ça fait trente deux
parties qu'il n'a pas gagné
mais tu sais toi qui aime bien les
métaphores
imagine si tu avais invité 32 fois une
meuf avoir un verre et qu'à chaque fois
ça chez marpa et là c'est la 33e
excuses mais ta technique doit être
assez dramatique non technique peut être
remise en question oui
non oui à tous les postes riblon et
participants avec quatre ans
non mais
mais est-ce qu'après autant due au temps
de brigue
ce que tu en es capable
on va voir la réponse ifef trois
solides à défaut qu'un les raisins à
continuer à mettre la pression et à mon
pronostic était mauvaise j'ai pris 12%
oui mais tu parles d'alireza jeunes
nos deux matches
ok maintenant à 500 tentes certes
l'ordinateur préfère dans beauce est
sûrement pour contrôler le truc rires
d'ailleurs peut-être une fois avant d'un
médecin anticipe tour ses quais à 5
sûrement parce que tout en a quatre qui
avaient dansé 2000 et pas incidents
comme ceux de
passe est dramatique non 6 et 17 non de
bourges reprises et ça il dit pas si
grave et si tu bouffes avec la tour
dramatique ok dramatique quand même
dramatique
traumatique ouais donc ça tu peux pas
juste alors dans beauce est trop aboli
certes
dégueulasse oui
[Rires]
le problème c'est quand
ils disent duda blender